[Musique]
Marie Tarli, bonsoir. Bonsoir. Nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview. Nous sommes en
direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement ? Ah, cette
phrase,
ça fait tellement bizarre de l'entendre.
Euh
six saintement femme 41 ans, métisse,
bretonne, créole, très fier de l'être.
Euh
et j'ai malheureusement je parle ni
breton ni créole par créol. Non non non,
ça c'est un peu mon mes grands regrets.
Euh comportementalistéquin,
euh navigatrice,
euh jeune conférencière, jeune écrivaine
et puis je me débrouille pour faire du
mieux que je peux avec tout ce que j'ai.
J'essaie d'être un bon être humain mais
c'est compliqué, on va dire.
On vous reçoit aujourd'hui pour parler
maire, entreprise papas bateau,
levé de fond, naviguer autour du monde
sans pens qu'on allait parler de l'Iran.
Moi aujourd'hui, je Non, ça c'était
hier. Tu sais qu'on t'a fait venir
aujourd'hui pour décompresser. Alors,
commence pas. OK. Donc, on va parler
naviguer, voile, peut-être chevaux,
peut-être perspective, perception,
passion. On commence par quoi ? Ce que
tu veux ? Ce que je veux les chevaux.
Avec plaisir. Ouais, avec plaisir.
Pourquoi les chevaux ? Euh, pourquoi les
chevaux ? J'ai pas vraiment choisi. J'ai
rencontré j'ai rencontré mon premier
cheval, j'avais 3 ans et demi, un étalon
Shetland qui s'appelait Jupiter. Euh, et
mon père était parti en mer, je ne sais
pas où. Je déprimais à la maison. Ma
mère m'a emmené aux écuries du Reden au
petit poney club du coin et ça c'était
le matin. Je me suis pris une gamelle
monstrueuse enfin une bonne bonne
gamelle avec Jupiter comme tous les
gamins. Et à l'idi, j'étais sur le pas
de la porte en train de bouffer de enfin
ma mère elle me tenait quoi pour pas que
je retourne directement dans la voiture
pour repartir au premier club. Et euh
l'après-midi monsieur Graal lui a dit
"Madame pour vous c'est foutu
comportementaliste.
Le ara de la sens le Montana. Ouais
ouais pas de parellie. pas eu la chance
de le rencontrer. Nous, on était avec
Andy Boss et puis après j'ai pas mal
roulé Boss avec d'autres personnes
encore. Mais ouais, j'ai mis longtemps
avant de trouver ce que ce que je
voulais faire dans l'équitation ou
comment le faire en fait. Euh comme Andy
Andy, tu peux pas contrôler un cheval
tant que tu contrôles pas toi-même. En
fait, c'est en fait c'est un long très
long apprentissage et puis je reviens de
très très loin donc
enfin émotionnellement parlant. Donc du
coup, ouais, c'est vraiment quand j'ai
quand j'ai rencontré le de la sens que
enfin toutes les lettres de l'alphabet
que j'avais vu en fait en étant proche
des chevaux depuis très longtemps ont
enfin fait un mot en fait et que ça a
commencé à avoir du sens et j'ai
commencé à comprendre comment prendre
l'autre personne enfin est-ce que ça
reste une personne mais qui fonctionne
pas comme nous parce que nous on est des
proies enfin on est des prédateurs
pardon tu on a les yeux de devant on pue
le sang on pue la viande et comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour parler avec une
proie qui n'a du coup pas les mêmes
réflexes, qui lui euh a des peurs
ancestrales et viscérales.
Nous, on monte sur son dos comme ça
facile alors que c'est la partie la plus
dangereuse et la plus vulnérable du
cheval. Dire pour eux, les prédateurs
vont sauter sur le dos, vont sauter à la
gorge, vont le mettre par terre puis
nous on se dit que bah monter sur un
cheval c'est easy quoi. Mais sauf que
c'est pour eux c'est d'une violence.
Si c'est pas bien fait, c'est fait d'une
violence inouie. Alors que si c'est bien
fait, c'est le cheval qui te dit "Tu
veux pas ?"
Et là, tu deviens partenaire avec lui et
tu es plus passager. En fait, c'est ça
qui est génial de pouvoir vraiment avoir
le cheval qui avec qui tu as vraiment un
compagnon et et puis tu es en train de
voler à mi-chemin entre ciel et terre où
il te permet en fait d'avoir cette ce
regardé
quoi. Qu'est-ce qu'on apprend sur les
hommes ?
Euh je sais pas ce que on apprend sur
les hommes de façon genre mais moi en
tout cas les les chevaux ce que j'ai
vraiment aimé c'est que dès le départ
comme les les êtres humains m'ont
beaucoup regardé parce que j'étais la
fille d'eux que il y avait beaucoup
d'intérêt beaucoup de jalousie beaucoup
de de de fantasme aussi fille de qui
déjà petit boulanger du coin
euh non je suis la fille d'Éric Éric
Tabarli et donc voilà ça donne une ça
c'est ça donne un rapport qui est hyper
faussé alors que toi tu vois les gens
pour ce qu'ils sont et eux te prennent
pas pour ce que tu es. Et et les chevaux
te prennent dans ton entièreté pour ce
que tu es et dans le moment présent, ils
se foutent de savoir d'où tu sors. Par
contre, ils te en 2 secondes, ils t'ont
scanné et ils te connaissent mieux que
ta propre mère. En seconde 3, tu rentres
dans le champ et qu'ils ont déjà vu ton
rythme cardiaque. Il sa exactement ce
que tu veux. Des émanations
d'adrénaline. Après, si tu peux arriver
avec de la tristesse, tu peux ils
peuvent en fonction, ils peuvent
encaisser. Ça dépend de comment tu la
gères. Est-ce que et la projection que
tu vas avoir sur eux ?
Euh c'est tu peux être stressé, tu peux
il y a il y a plein de choses qui sont
capables d'absorber mais après ça dépend
de comment tu travailles avec cette
émotion là. Donc ça qui est vachement
intéressant. Donc ce que j'essaie de
faire avec les gens et ce que mon
équipage lui a vraiment fait autour du
monde c'est qu'ils sont à chaque fois
ils ont pu voir les gens pour les autres
pour ce qu'ils étaient eux réellement et
pas la projection que tu as de l'autre
personne. Et ça c'est agréable. Enfin
c'est du bien quoi. C'est Est-ce que les
gens apprécient quand tu tu lis en eux
comme un livre ouvert ?
Je je sais Ouais, j'arrive je sais je
lis pas je lis pas en eux comme les
comme dans les ouvrirs pas pas pas pas
les humains. Les humains sont trop
compliqués encore. Ils mentent, ils se
cachent. Il c'est les chevaux ne mentent
pas. Que c'est l'humain. Des fois il y
en a qui mentent hein. Les chevaux il y
en a qui te simulent des boîteries parce
qu'ils ont pas envie de basser. Ils sont
fatigués, tu les emmerdes. Ben ça oui
mais ça m pas. Ça c'est un message c'est
un message que tu as pas voulu voir
avant en fait. Si le cheval il fait pas,
il y a trois options. C'est soit il sait
pas faire et c'est ta faute, tu lui as
pas suffisamment bien expliqué, soit il
est pas motivé de le faire. Euh et ça
c'est ta faute parce qu' il a pas
l'envie. Soit physiquement il peut pas
faire et ça c'est ta faute. Soit tu l'as
pas suffisamment bien entraîné, soit tu
lui demandes pas ce ce dont pourquoi il
est fait quoi. Donc il y a un moment
mais ça dans c'est comme dans le monde
des humains, c'est moi sur le bateau
tout est de la faute du capitaine. Euh
soit j'ai pas bien mis mon équipage en
condition enfin soit enfin voilà il y a
plein de ça ça on peut transposer.
Ouais. On va parler de ton équipage. On
va parler comment recruter un équipage
avec 70 % d'amateurs. On va parler
bateau, vague brun, Albatros, lion de
mer, caporne et et tour du monde. Ouais.
Ton bouquin, il m'a un il y a des
passages où tu te mars, il y a des
passages où tu tu voyages, il y a des
passage où on rentre dans ta tête, on
voit tes angoisses. C'est quoi tes plus
grosses angoisses quand tu pars avec 70
% d'amateurs sur un super bateau ?
Comment c'est le Black Shark, c'est ça ?
Ouais, mais il a une tête d'orc, tu le
vois de profil, ça fait une sorte de
gros orc énorme, tu devant toi avec plus
avec les feux de navigation, ça fait
deux petits yeux sur le côté. Donc il a
et puis ouais un bateau hors de l'eau,
c'est quelque chose quoi. C'est vraiment
ça a une dimension
mais lui que ce soit à terre enfin que
que tu passes à côté sur le quai ou
qu'il soit à terre, il a un truc, il a
un magnétisme qui est incroyable. Et
papa qui l'a designé André Moric sur une
commande de mon père. Ouais ouais ouais
mais il a il a un charisme. Il a un
charisme de fou. Ouais. 50 ans le
bateau. 51 maintenant. Ouais. Ouais. Non
mais superbe. Je 51 et puis à chaque
fois que je que je monte à bord, tu pu
parce que ça fait quand même maintenant
41 ans qu'on se connaît quand même. Min
euh
il y a toujours ce il y a jamais de
lassitude. C'était un peu ma trouille
avant de partir au tour du monde. C'est
on a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
navigué. Il me dit "Est-ce que après le
tour du monde j'aurais pas envie de
passer à autre chose ?" Et en fait non.
Puis je peux toujours aller naviguer sur
d'autres bateaux. J'ai plein d'autres
manau sur lequel naviguer. Euh des plus
modernes qui vont plus vite et et ça
c'est mon compagnon de vie en fait.
C'est ça qui est euh il sait pas comme
un cheval ou tu là j'ai un jeune cheval
qui a 5 ans, ben je vais le former et
puis il va finir comme mon autre cheval
qui a qui est en retraite qui a qui a
plus de 20 ans. Et là il y a pas de fin
en fait tant que tu l'entretiens bien il
a aucune raison que qui a de fin. mon
premier Pendi qui a est né en 1898.
Donc
ça c'est des bateaux qui vont nous
passer, qui vont nous survivre sans
problème. S'il y a un bon le tout c'est
de bien les entretenir
avec le respect et la technique enfin
dont ils ont besoin quoi. Ça coûte cher.
Non non
du coup il y en a un.
Non, le bateau, le cheval, c'est bien.
Non non, j'ai choisi deux passions de
passion tout dans le pif. Un vrai chien
de chasse.
Bien sûr, ça coûte cher. Ouais, c'est en
fait ça coûte pas aussi cher qu'un imoka
ou tu les bateaux du vent des globes qui
sont en carbone avec des foiles, avec
des trucs. Le problème c'est que moi ces
bateaux là c'est des bateaux du
patrimoine. Ils sont ils sont ils sont
classés monument historique depuis cette
année. Et de toute manière, c'est des
bateaux sur lesquels jamais j'avais
accepté avant de mettre des grands
logos. Tu peux euh tu peux mettre un
logo sur sur une Formule 1. Tu vas pas
mettre un logo sur un roadster Jaguar
des années 50. Tu sur n'importe quelle
voiture de collection, tu vas dénaturer
la voiture. La voiture n'appartient pas
au partenaire et ça en plus
esthétiquement c'est très très moche et
en plus ça va desservir le partenaire en
fait. C'est donc du coup trouver des des
partenaires qui acceptent de suivre des
projets comme ça, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué parce que il y a moins de
médiatisation derrière et c'est une
autre histoire qu'il faut raconter.
C'est mais ça se raconte et et on en
trouve quand même heureusement. Il y a
raconte un bout de ton tour du monde.
Bah ça dépend lequel. Enfin c'était long
quand même. Le moment le moment où tu as
pris le plus de plaisir, le moment où tu
t'es le plus marré, le moment où tu n'as
pas montré tes angoisses et le moment où
tu es arrivé.
Euh le moment où j'ai pris le plus de
plaisir euh
Ouais, ouais, ouais, ouais. Et puis en
fait, c'est pas des longues périodes, il
y a même les périodes d'angoisse en
fait, c'est tous les jours, il y a une
nouvelle émotion, une nouvelle sensation
et une nouvelle beauté qui se dégage de
la journée. En fait, il y a toujours un
truc bien. Puis en plus, comme on se
marre tous sur le bateau, il y a
toujours un moment où tu rigoles. Il y a
des endroits que j'ai un peu préféré.
Ouais. le long de l'Atlantique, enfin le
long du Brésil, pardon, quand tu passes
en Atlantique Sud et que là les lumières
elles deviennent parce qu'on est quand
même tous les jours dans le même
environnement, hein. C'est de l'eau par
c'est de l'eau en bas, du ciel en haut,
quelquefois des oiseaux qui changent
mais voilà c'est mais c'est tous les
jours différent quoi. C'est y a il y a
aucune monotonie. C'est incroyable.
C'est c'est et le long du Brésil, ça
devient bleu.
Une sorte de de de bleu hyper profond,
très très lumineux, très très
chaleureux. C'est c'est superbe. Enfin,
c'est les nuits, elles sont dingues. Ça
te fait des étoiles.
C'est c'est absolument dingue. Mais tu
es dans Avatar quoi. Tu es vraiment
dedans quoi. C'est Saf que ça existe tu
en le plancton. Ouais ouais. Non mais tu
as tout hein. Tuasas tuas le planqueton,
les dauphins qui t'attaquent qui
arrivent de hyper loin et non mais il
t'attaquent pas mais tu as toujours
l'impression qu'il genre tu les as pas
vu alors que tu as une traînée de
planqueton qui immense euh non c'est
superbe. Mais le gris du grand sud même
s'il est terrifiant parce que tu es
quand même pas fait pour y aller. Enfin
c'est tu as quand même un grand panneau
à l'entrée qui marque ne restez pas là
trop longtemps. Euh vous êtes que de
passage.
Ça reste ça reste un truc où que tu as
envie de voir et de revoir tous les
jours tellement que c'est prenant quoi.
C'est hyper intense.
[Musique]
Il y a des Ouais, il y a des puis il y a
des moments où oui, ça fait
un peu chaud au fess quand même hein.
Bah
la dépression avant le horn, c'est sûr
que très très impressionnante. Euh pét
non non dépression au contraire.
dépression, tu as beaucoup beaucoup de
vent euh beaucoup de vent et en terme de
qui de nœud ou de kilomèh, c'était pas
le pire qu'on a affronté mais euh
mais euh mais des masses d'eau, mais
c'est une c'est des masses d'eau
énormes, quoi. Parce qu'en fait dans le
Pacifique, tu as tu as rien qui va
bloquer la le train de houle. Donc tu as
pas de tu as pas de continent, tu as pas
de barrière. Donc euh les vagues ont
vraiment le temps de se former et de
très très loin et euh et là et puis en
plus tu es en course donc tu es pas du
tout là pour pour ralentir ou quoi que
ce soit puis tu as tes petits copains là
nous c'était les Italiens qui étaient en
même temps que nous. Je savais que Nico
il allait tirer sur le bateau. J'étais
ça c'est un moment qu' qu'on navigue
l'un contre l'autre. Lui je pouvais bien
le lire par contre. Comment euh Nico
Malingry de Translated N et euh et là
ouais c'était sûr qu'ils allaient tirer
sur le bateau. Donc nous on a tiré
dessus aussi. Puis de toute manière dans
les grosses vagues, tu es obligé de
garder de la vitesse. La vitesse, ça va
être ta sécurité si tu si tu ralentis.
Du coup, tu auras un bateau qui va être
moins manœuvrant. Tu vas te faire
prendre par par la vague et alors là
c'est là c'est pas drôle du tout.
Et mais voilà, tu sais que tu es c'est
il y a tout après cette cette image même
si techniquement tu ça ça déroule, tu as
pas de cast, il y a tout va bien, tu
gardes quand même un petit truc du dire
"Attends là, on arrive au Caporne quand
même." Donc c'est pas déjà vu des vagues
célérates ? Non, célérates non, j'en ai
une qui m'a bien défoncé la gueule.
Ouais, mais c'était pas une vague
céléérate
mais j'en ai une qui a couché pendux au
niveau des assorts.
Et quand tu vois la taille du bateau,
se retrouver avec le bateau avec les
mains qui sont au moins, c'était minimum
à l'horizontal, je sais pas si ça a été
plus que j'ai pas vu. Euh
là, j'ai absolument rien pu faire. Puis
tu la vois arriver, c'estàd que j'avais
j'étais à la barre à ce moment-là.
Heureusement, j'étais moi, je mets très
peu de gilet, ça me ça me saoule. Euh
ouais, je sais, c'est pas bien mais bon,
je suis la fille de mon père, qu'est-ce
que tu veux ? Euh par contre, j'ai
toujours un boudriiller et je me vache à
toi avec des des petites longes de 30 cm
quoi. Et au contraire, du coup, je suis
toujours vaché très très court proche du
bateau. Tant que si tu veux, de toute
manière, il a un moment on va tellement
vite si tomber même avec un avec une
longe, c'est pas une option parce que tu
te fais écarteler, tu te fais tu
remonter le temps même le temps de
remonter, enfin c'est pas forcément une
bonne idée. Moi mon choix personnel, je
préfère crever vite quoi.
Pourquoi ? Bon parce que je pense pas
que la la mort paranoyade avec une
lentagonie soit vachement plus sympa
quoi. Mais euh mais au moins je avec ces
quand je me vache court bah voilà je
sais que je peux pas tomber quoi. Donc
j'ai plein de systèmes de vache où du
coup je peux me double vacher. Enfin
voilà je j'aime la vie et je veux rester
sur mon bateau. Mais est-ce que tomber
n'est pas une option quoi. Et donc là
j'étais bien vaché au bateau et quand la
il y a une première vague qui arrive et
qui qui m'entraîne pas dans son surf en
fait. Pourtant, je regarde les
compteurs, on est à 11 nœuds 11 nœud 5.
C'est une très bonne vitesse. Il y a pas
de souci. Mais moi, j'ai cette sensation
d'être collé au gazon quoi. De pas
pouvoir du tout avancer. Enfin, deê
d'avoir un truc qui me retient un peu
par derrière quoi. T'aspire par
derrière. Ouais. C'était et euh comme si
tu marchais à contesens d'un tapis
roulant, c'est ça ? Ouais, c'est un peu
ça. C'est un peu ça. Et euh et là, en me
retournant pour lire la vague d'après,
je vois un truc mais énorme droit et
puis pas du tout avec la pente comme les
surfeurs vont partir avec. Normalement,
nous on part avec ça. Là, elle est
droite et elle arrive comme ça. Et du
coup, je sais que si quand elle va
déferler, bah ça va ça va faire mal.
Enfin, tuas tu vas te prendre des on va
se prendre des litres d'eau et et là je
vois pas comment positionner le bateau
parce que si je lui présente le cul, ça
va pas. Si je lui présente le flanc du
bateau, ça va pas aller non plus. J'ai
dit bon bah fais ce que tu veux quoi.
Fais ce que tu veux. Il y avait
personne, heureusement c'éit une relève
de car, il y avait personne sur le pont.
Il y en avait un qui commençait à
sortir.
Euh et là le bateau il s'est couché mais
ça a été un plaquage.
Ça a été John Hallomou le truc hein. Ça
a été Il s'est adressé comment tout seul
? il y a la qui fait son travail et puis
euh enfin pendant un moment je me suis
retrouvé donc tu es pendu dans le truc,
j'avais même je sentais plus du tout le
le le le bateau sous moi ni quoi que ce
soit. Tu as des milliers de litres qui
te passent comme ça et
et puis a un moment la ki fait le
travail, le bateau se se relève, la
vague est passée et alors là les voiles
elles se regonflent directement. Le
bateau il a rien senti, il est reparti
comme ça. Moi j'étais et là j'essayé de
barrer mais au bout de 10 minutes, j'ai
appelé mon second j'y arrivais plus.
Enfin, je veux dire là, tu as un tel
trop de
d'adré de tout de de
J'avais l'impression qu'il y en avait
que des comme ça alors qu'en fait
c'était en plus les c'était facile à
barrer avant c'était c'était hyper
funky. C'était il y avait des grosses
conditions, il y a grosses conditions de
boule mais on avait quoi du 7 8 m de
creux 40 nœuds de vent mais c'était Non
mais ça allait je dire il y avait pas
franchement ça allait il y avait pas on
avait eu bien pire avant et puis comme
les vagues étaient assez organisées à ce
moment-là c'était assez drôle quoi.
Elles étaient assez organisées ou tu
avais une assez bonne lecture ? Non je
pense qu'elles étaient assez organisées
quoi. J'ai je celle-là je sais pas d'où
je sais pas d'où elle est sortie quoi.
Alors à l'intérieur du bateau, ça était
une scène de guerre parce que c'était le
petit âge en plus.
OK. Alors là, tu as tout qu'à voler. Il
y en a une qui s'est fait mal et très
mal parce que bah quand quand le bateau
se couche, bah mine 2, tu fais une chute
de plus de 4 m, tu traverses les
cabines, bam, comme ça. Euh donc elle
s'est pété une vertèbre et le bateau
fait 20 m de long, 22 m 25, ouais, c'est
pour 5 m 35 de large et 34 tonnes. Et
les mains font 25 m à peu près. Les
avait souffert ou pas ? Non, non, non,
mais rien. Le bateau, il sait même pas
qu'il a fait un tour du monde, hein. Il
lui il est arrivé en meilleur état qu'il
est parti. Euh il est Non non, lui il
est fantastique. On va revenir sur ton
équipage et ton tour du monde. Après
pendant pendant que tu naviguais, est-ce
que tu as vu des signes de notre société
thermoindustrielle qui polluent, qui
dégueulassent tout ? Est-ce que tu as vu
des pirates ? Est-ce que tu as vu des îs
de plastique ? Est-ce que tu as vu des
tortues qui avaient des pailles dans le
nez ou prises dans des filets ? Est-ce
que tu as vu des marques d'hélical ?
Est-ce que tu as vu des voit
les voit pas exactement comme ça parce
qu'en fait on voit pas déjà la pollution
on la voit très très peu qu'en général
ça coule tout simplement. Donc comme
c'est loin des yeux et que ça coule bon
on s'en fout hein, ça n'existe pas euh
malheureusement. Euh donc ça, on en voit
assez peu. Ce qu'on notre terreur c'est
les containers parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de paquebo enfin de cargo qui soit
perdent leur cargaison leur chargement
soit bah en cas de vraiment très gros
temps il largu et et quand tu vois le
nombre de cargos
prends un jour la carte de marine trafic
tu regardes
Finding vaissel tu regardes la le nombre
de cargos qu'il y a sur l'océan c'est
assez vertigineux
et c'est en temps réel quand le cargo
C'est c'était comment ça ? Evergreen
c'était c'était dans le canal de Suède
s'était planté. C'était génial parce que
du coup tu le voyais lui en travers un
drift. Ouais. Et c'est chaud he pour
passer he c'est vraiment pas large he.
Donc après tu voyais tous les petits
remorqueurs qui passaient et puis
surtout tu as vu tout le trafic qui
mondial qui est passé du coup sous
l'Amérique enfin sous l'Afrique du Sud
et qui s'est réorganisé pendant un
moment. Mais et ça les les les
containers qui sont entre deux eau.
Ouais, c'est ça c'est terrifiant parce
que là c'est sûr qu'entre lui et nous
c'est nous qui allons avoir mal. Ouais.
Euh
des animaux marins, oui, on en a vu
beaucoup. euh accidenté euh on le sait
pas toujours. En général quand même la
grande proportion va bien. Euh moi ce
qui m'a vraiment marqué cette année euh
ce que déjà c'est qu'on est des
phénomènes météo, ça fait quand même pas
mal de temps qu'on voit qu'on est plus
sur un papier à musique, c'est plus
réglé comme avant. Là, on a plein de
choses qui sont très très bizarres en
fonction des périodes. Des alisées qui
sont pas du tout installées,
des du très très petit temps dans le
grand sud ou des cartouches qui arrivent
de nulle part. Tu en 2019, on s'est pris
une dépression aux assorts au mois
d'octobre, mais on était à 125 nœuds,
130 nœuds à peu près un truc là, enfin
octobre, pas du tout normal. Euh c'est
un ouragan qui s'appelait Lorenzo à
l'époque. Euh et il y a plein plein de
petits phénomènes comme ça.
C'était quand ? C'était la dernière
route du Rome où les Alés n'étaient pas
du tout établis et ils s'établissent de
moins en moins. Enfin, il y a plein de
choses qui sont en train de changer. Moi
ce qui m' ce que je connaissais pas par
contre,
je savais qu'il y avait de la piraterie
évidemment.
quand tu cumules les Nous on passe dans
le grand sud donc ça il y a pas grand
monde qui passe mais j'avais à un moment
imaginé un autre pour une autre exp
d'aller à l'expo universel qui est à
Dubaï et quand tu mets la carte de la
piraterie la carte du transport de
drogue la carte de vente d'arme euh là
tu fais que la mer est quand même bien
occupée et que c'est un peu compliqué on
va éviter de passer par là ouais il y a
plein d'endroits où il faut quand même
évit et tu es armé sur ton bateau non je
suis pas armé Euh je suis pas armée
parce que bon déjà on n pas on a pas le
droit et de deux c'est les
internationales. Ouais c'est les
internationales. Mais faut être sûr si
tu es armé que
si tu sors ton arme, tu dois être sûr de
tirer parce que l'autre en face il
hésitera pas. Et euh bon, on a tous été
un petit peu traumatisé par l'histoire
de Peter Black euh qui se fait descendre
en Amazonnie sur son bateau. Il y a un
moment où Ouais, tu faut faut faire un
peu attention quand même. Pour
l'instant, je vais pas trop naviguer
dans ces endroits-là. Par contre, en
passant le hornne, nous notre étape,
elle arrivait à à Punta de Lesté en
Uruguay et le long de l'Amérique latine
euh je sais plus exactement où on était
euh mais on était évidemment dans les
eaux internationales
et je sors sur le pont et je vois des
était de nuit mais je regarde la lune.
[__] le lever de lune aujourd'hui
et j'ai Kaï qui un de mes pros qui me
dit "Non mais la lune, elle est là
quoi." Je Mais il y a aucune terre par
là quoi.
Et finalement, il y a un lot lumineux
mais énorme. Pche au calamar.
Non non non, c'était loin. C'était hyper
loin mais tu c'est c'est et en fait ça
c'est des c'est des bateaux chinois qui
tu en as 100 200 qui sont agglutinés les
uns aux autres et puis tu as plein de
spots un peu comme ça tant qu'il teint
tu en tombe sur un autre qui mettent les
spots à fond et qui a des lumières un
peu vertes et qui attirent le calamar
comme ça et
et en plus donc évidemment ça ça défonce
le Canada ça défonce toute la ressource
et il y a pas que là il y a il y a
d'autres d'autres endroits
Euh mais c'est surtout que c'est des
conditions de vie enfin c'est
l'esclavage moderne. Les mecs ils
restent plusieurs années sur les bateaux
quoi. Euh je connais pas exactement les
euh le dossier mais euh mais a priori
ouais tu ils peuvent rester 1 an 2 ans
voire plus sans débarquer. Euh bon si tu
es malade tu es pas très bien. Si tu es
mort voilà. Cool. Ouais. Euh et en fait
tu as juste des bateaux et c'est les
bateaux, ils sont dans des états
d'élabrement lamentables. Euh pour
certains, ils ont même plus de moteur.
Donc comme ça tu es sûr de pas rentrer
et puis voilà, en fait, tu as juste des
bateaux qui viennent choper la cargaison
et qui repartent. Tu es passé près d'eux
ou pas ? On est pas alors nous on n'est
pas passé près d'eux. Il y en a d'autres
de la flotte qui sont passés un peu plus
près mais par contre on les entend à la
VHF. Ouais, ça on les entend. Nous, on
est parti autour du monde sans sans
satellite, donc on avait pas de moyen de
communication moderne. Euh on
localisation sextant, localisation au
sextant et réception des fichiers météo
par BLU. Donc c'est des radio longue
fréquence.
Voilà. Donc mais par contre la VHF du
coup on avait le droit et ça par contre
on les entend ça inondait les canaux à
la VHF quoi. On sait qu'ils étaient
chinois, ça c'est sûr. La BLU.
Ah la vu c'est top. Ça fait toujours une
voix un peu bizarre. Ouais bah après ça
dépend de il y a des mystères hein.
C'estagation solaire. Ouais. Alors en
fonction de s'il y a des s'il y a des de
la rotondité de la terre, en fonction
s'il y a une éruption solaire ou pas, il
y a des moments le bateau d'à côté on
l'attendait pas. Alors que le bateau en
que de ploton qui était vraiment très
très loin, on l'entendait super bien
quoi. Donc c'était il y a des il y a des
petits mystères sur la BLU.
C'est mais c'était drôle et c'était
vraiment sympa de pouvoir. On avait
quatre vacations par jour en fait. Il y
avait une vacation pour les Frenchis
qu'on était sur 14 bateaux, il y avait
je crois sep français sep bateaux
français puis le reste était il y avait
vraiment international. Il y avait des
Italiens, des Américains, des
Finlandais. Il y a deux bateaux
finlandais,
euh les anglais, espagnol
euh et euh du coup, il y a une vacation
française le matin et le soir et une
autre vacation plus internationale matin
et soir. Donc on peut se donner les
positions à chaque fois euh estimé bien
sûr. Euh on donnait la position, la
direction du vent, la force du vent, la
pression atmosphérique. Et comme ça,
comme on avait très peu d'informations
météo, tout le monde jouait le jeu et on
pouvait redessiner aussi un minim un peu
de cartes, tu vois, un peu de avoir un
peu de données quoi. Bon, le problème,
c'est que du coup nous on était la météo
souvent des autres. Vu qu'on était en
tête, ben ils savaient à peu près ce
qu'on ce qu'ils allaient avoir.
Euh et puis c'était assez agréable en
fait de parler. Il y a un code à la BLU,
tu vois, tuas tu appelles les autres
bateaux, tout le monde se présente, tu
peux pas parler en tout le monde en même
temps. Il y avait des blagues qui se
faisaient, il y avait des gens, tu
savais plus du tout à quoi il
ressemblaient, ce que tu avais pas eu le
temps de savoir. Du coup, tu les
connaissais hyper bien mais en blague à
la BLU ou mais arrivé à terre, tu sais
pas du tout à quoi il ressemblait. Euh
et puis il y avait dès que tu avais un
problème, tu pouvais demander au reste
de la flotte. Il y avait toujours soit
un médecin, soit un mécanicien qui avait
une solution. On essaie de s'entraider
comme ça pas mal. En fait, c'est là où
c'est vraiment sympa ce genre de course
là. Et puis puis on ce qu'on retrouve
aussi, je pense même si même sur un vent
des Globes parce que un vent des Globes,
il y a un WhatsApp pour les coureurs et
ils se parlent, ils échangent. Après,
ils vont cacher, ils vont pas non plus
donner euh des conseils, trop de
conseils quand même parce que là, il y a
voilà. Mais mais euh tu vois nous euh il
y a un bateau bah c'était White Shadow
quand on passe en on passe le Horn, on
est passé dans un D3 qui s'appelle le D3
de le mer. C'est juste vraiment à la au
niveau de la Patagonie tout en bas, il y
a des maré forcément parce que bah tu
passes vraiment dans un D3, tu vois les
deux côtés quoi, tu vois vraiment la
terre que ce que tu as pas vu depuis
assez longtemps. Il cétait parti sans
les horaires de maré. Donc du coup,
j'entends à la BLU que il sait pas du
tout à quelle heure il va avoir enfin il
peut passer. Donc moi je lui donne le
j'allais lui donner ça et j'ai négocié
une tournée de Kirinia en arrivant à
Punta Bgada.
Mon équipage m'appelle Kai Pitan parce
que j'adore la K Pirinia.
Comment on fait la la caille Pierinia ?
Avec une très bonne cache à ça. Il faut
surtout une bonne cache à ça mais plein
de gazil bon citron bon sucre de canne
et pas du sirop. Il y a des bars qui te
font ça au sirop shaker ça n'a aucun
sens. Revenons, revenons à la voile.
La piraterie chez les marins, ça en
parle beaucoup. Est-ce que ceux qui vont
faire des course se parlent de ce
sujet-là ? Est-ce qu'il parle de
l'écologie ? Est-ce qu'il se racontent
des choses ? Est-ce qu'il voi notre
monde différemment quand il rentre ?
Est-ce qu'il y a un stress
post-traumatique quand tu réintègres la
société ? Quand tu vois un hiver pourri,
les gens font la gueule, il y a Bruno
Leer qui parle à la télé, des trucs
comme ça, tu vois ?
Euh
alors la piraterie, nous on passe très
rarement par c par des zones touchées
par ça. Donc ça va migrant on peut
tomber dessus. Euh ça c'est la antise.
La antise c'est tomber sur du migrant
quoi. Pourquoi la antise ? Parce qu'on
peut pas les aider. Tu vois, en général,
tu te retrouves avec un zodiaque avec 50
personnes, 80 personnes,
tu peux pas les faire monter sur ton
bateau quoi. C'est ou c'est bateaux qui
sont trop petits pour accueillir autant
de monde. Enfin, c'est tu peux rester,
les accompagner, déclarer, assister,
mais récupérer des gamins, c'est Ouais.
Après, honnêtement, je sais pas
exactement jusqu'où tu peux aller quoi
parce qu'il y a quand même pas Moi, ça
m'est heureusement jamais arrivé. Là, il
y a un bateau sur la course qui est
tombé au large de on passé où ? On passé
dernières île, on passé Canari. Ouais.
Euh,
ils sont tombés sur un mec tout seul sur
un bateau qui était clairement pas
pêcheur. Euh, plus d'essence, plus de
bouffe, plus d'eau, plus rien. Et donc,
ils l'ont remorqué, ils l'ont emmené
jusqu'à Dakar.
Euh
et d'autres part en Méditerranée ou même
en manche he qui tu peux tu peux tomber
sur Heureusement la marine nationale
fait un super beau travail là-dessus
mais que il y a il y a il y a vraiment
du monde hein sur l'eau quoi là de ça
qui demande de l'aide et puis bah une
tête d'homme qu'importe d'où tu viennes,
ça fait ça fait ça dans l'eau quoi. Donc
et ouais c'est terrifiant parce que du
coup tu faut faut pas non plus se mettre
trop en danger. Enfin, c'est euh
quand tu rentres à terre bah écoute,
c'est simple, nous on est parti le 10
septembre 2023 pour 40 jours de mer.
Donc on est arrivé à Cap Town fin
octobre, tu rallumes ton téléphone, tu
vois les conflits israélo-palestiniens
explosé mais géné comprenait pas si tu
veux qu'on tu passe tu passes de off à
on quoi. Tu as tellement d'infos et puis
d'infos dans le désordre du coup parce
que bah tu essayes de remonter un peu
trianguler ta source. Ouais c'est c'est
c'est et puis et puis tu as pas tu as
pas envie quoi juste tout le monde était
à fond pro Israël. OK, d'accord. Bon, il
nous reste 2 semaines à terre, on repart
40 jours, tout le monde a rebasculé,
tout le monde propicine puis tout le
monde qui donne son avis qui alors qui
devrait surtout pas ça va dans tous les
sens.
On change de gouvern de de premier
ministre, enfin c'est plein plein plein
plein plein d'autos, ça a été ultra
chargé.
Et on est arrivé en avril, donc ça
faisait 8 mois qu'on était en course.
Mais bon, nous ça fait quasiment 2 ans
qu'on était en mer. Donc on a quand même
ça fait 2 ans, plus de 2 ans que je vis
dans un sac qui a plus de maison, qui a
pu clairement dans un autre et c'était
les élections européennes quoi.
C'était bien, c une bonne période.
Sortie d'hiver, ça faisait deux hivers,
deux étés qui pleuvaient des Canadaires,
tout le monde était déprimé. Euh là, tu
avais des nouvelles élections qui
arrivaient, c'était un délire
incroyable. Honnêtement, c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je vote pas.
En fait, c'est J'ai pas réussi. Je vous
dis mais je n'étais plus dans le jeu
quoi. C'était le grand jeu des humains.
J'étais plus du tout dedans. Je voyais
pas pour qui, pourquoi, comment.
Et puis a un moment tu tu te rends
compte que le problème, il est tellement
pas là. Enfin, viens les gars, ouvrez
les yeux, on y va. On est on n plus du
tout en train d'essayer de sauver les
meubles là. C'est c'est foutu de toute
manière. Enfin, je dire il y a un moment
faut faut donc euh Ouais, j'ai mis un
peu de temps avant de évidemment je suis
par devoir évidemment je suis retourné
voter derrière. Euh mais ouais, le choc
il est le choc il est très très violent
sur en plus il y a tous les autres à
côté qui font que parce que tu pars en
vacances de semaines, ta boîte aux
lettres elle explose, ta boîte mail,
elle explose au bout de 8 mois, bout de
8 mois voir 2 ans,
c'est sympa aussi. Et donc tu as plein
de petits dossiers euh la maladie qui
touche certains de tes proches.
Tu tes amis euh tu as perdu plein
d'infos parce que tu étais pas là et que
bah quand ils te racontent leur vie mine
d'eux, il y a plein de détails qu'ils
oublient et qui et ouais tu mets tu mets
un moment à rentrer. Moi je suis rentré
je suis arrivé physiquement en avril
2024.
Euh, il m'aura fallu 11 mois, 2 mois
dans un refuge, un livre et un burnout
pour rentrer. Je suis rentrée au mois de
mars 2025.
J'arrive toujours pas à me dire qu'on
est en 2025. En fait, l'année sur la
liste, je toujours obligé de réfléchir.
Il manque un il manque un bout. Mais
quand je parle avec mes copains qui ont
fait le globe, il y en a en a pas mal
qui sont encore en phase de
d'atterrissage, hein. Ils sont rentrés
en mois de février, de mars. Le temps
que tu de d'atterrissage, c'est le temps
passé en mer. Donc moi, j'en ai pour 1 à
2 ans à peu près. Là, je suis pas mal
dans mes bottes là quand même. C'est
bien. Quel regard tu porte sur
toutes ces guerres, toutes tout ce
malheur C'est pas censé être feelg
aujourd'hui. Si, pardon,
c'est toi qui balance sur les migrants.
Ouais, bah ouais. Ouais, mais bon, c'est
sûr que non. Enfin, faut être un minimum
lucide hein. C'est Il y en a un
journaliste qui m'a posé la question
l'autre jour. Comment est-ce que vous
imaginez la course large dans 50 ans ?
mitraillette, je sais pas que le monde
dans 50 ans, il va pas être pour
l'instant, il a pas l'air d'être super
drôle, hein. C'est pas euh
bon, économiquement, je sais pas du tout
comment ça va être dans 50 ans déjà.
Enfin voilà, on sait très bien que ce
qui arrive n'est pas très drôle. Euh
mais quand on va devoir se prendre des
températures létales, parce que c'est ça
qui va arriver, euh ça va pas être drôle
du tout.
Donc là, on va se retrouver avec des
mouvements de population incroyables.
Euh
j'ai beaucoup de mal encore à imaginer.
Enfin, c'est normal, je pense. Enfin,
comme tout humain, quoi. On connaît le
monde là tel qu'il est. Euh, ça va pas
du tout rester comme ça. Ça t'a perturbé
énormément que le système météorologique
ne soit plus aussi stable que du temps
de ton père, que tu vois en fait ton
biotope changer totalement. Et quand tu
rentres, quand tu tu vois des gens qui
contestent
ce changement climatique, tu as envie de
leur dire quoi ? Tu es pas bien informé
? Tuvres pas assez tes yeux ? C'est même
pas à eux qu'il faut parler. Enfin, je
veux dire, il y a un moment où c'est
malheureusement c'est pas à eux que j'en
veux, hein. C'est comme tu vois les
platistes ou des ce goûl. à un moment
ils sont sympas les platistes. Non mais
ils sont très sympas, il y a pas de
problème. Enfin peut-être, je sais pas,
j'ai jamais rencontré un platiste. Moi
j'ai j'ai fait le tour, j'ai vu qu'elle
était ronde dire bon maintenant ils
pourront toujours dire mais non tu peux
pas parce que il pour retrouver plein
d'excuses. Le problème c'est comment
est-ce qu'on est arrivé là en fait ?
Comment est-ce qu'on arrive à avoir
maintenant des une perte de pied total ?
C'est tout le système qui a été un peu
mis en place avant qui fait que on se
met à réfléchir comme ça. C'est bien le
doute. Il faut avoir du doute hein. Il
faut il faut mais là il y a il y a a y a
il y a beaucoup trop quoi. Il y a
beaucoup trop et l'écoute des sens en
eux-mêmes euh
on s'est complètement déconnecté de
notre corps, de la de de la nature, de
ce qu'elle nous envoie, de la lecture
simple des choses quoi. Donc euh après
c'est peut-être aussi un
refuge de du cerveau aussi de de pas
vouloir voir aussi un déni quoi. Donc ça
arrive souvent en politique ou il
paraît. Ouais.
Quand tu sélectionnes un équipage Ouais.
comment ça se passe ?
Euh alors pour ce tour du monde là,
j'étais un peu joueuse. J'ai je suis
repartie d'une d'une page blanche par
rapport à ce que j'avais avant.
et euh je voulais pas repartir avec des
gens avec qui j'avais déjà navigué. Et
euh bon, les pros, je les je les
connaissais. On avait pas forcément
naviguer ensemble, mais je savais que ça
allait bien se passer avec eux. En fait,
nous on est 12 à bord. Euh 18 à 50 ans.
Ouais, mais avant ça, on est on est 12
si tu veux dans l'organisation. c'est
que tu as moi en capitaine, après j'ai
mes trois chefs de car et qui eux sont
professionnels et en dessous j'ai mes
matelots et euh et à côté de ça, j'ai ma
chef chef cuistau qui est la personne
qui me fait le plus peur à peu à bord et
tout le monde veut être la la pote de la
chef, je veux dire, c'est ça c'est c'est
déjà et puis c'est elle qui fait la
bouffe quoi. Donc c'est ta meilleure
amie, quoi. Mais ouais mais c'est
important dans le grand sud.
Et euh donc elle comme c'est un c'est un
vrai job et c'est compliqué quoi. Tu
dois faire à manger deux fois par jour
pour 12 personnes agité à 40 45°gr c'est
des 44 he ces nanas elles sont
incroyables. Et donc elle elle est hors
quart et les autres le reste du bateau
fonctionne en quart de 3h. C'est-à-dire
que pendant 3h tu es on donc ené capelé
sur le pont. 3h après tu as 3h de repos.
Donc tu es off à ce moment-là et après
tu as la période de standby. Donc
c'estàd que s'il se passe rien, tu peux
rester dormir. S'il y a une manœuvre, je
suis c'est le premier car que j'appelle
et je laisse de préférence le car qui
est off en train de dormir. Euh et ça va
rouler comme ça pendant pendant tout le
tour. Et donc eux ils peuvent si ça se
trouve ils peuvent passer 3h sur le pont
et 6h de repos. Après dans les 6h de
repos, il faut prendre soin de toi,
aider aider la chef à tu éplucher les
légumes et tout ça, réparer le bateau
parce qu'il y a toujours des petits
trucs à faire, le ménage, entretenir
tout ça, participer à la vie du bord en
fait.
Et dans ce quart de 3h, en général, ils
ont 1 heure de barre et pendant l'heure
de barre, je veux qu'il soit à 100 %
focus, quoi. Donc ils ont ils ont 1
heure de barre toutes les 9h. Là, je
leur tire dessus quoi. Et moi, je suis
hors quart, donc c'est un peu
anarchique. Je peux rest très bien euh
ne pas dormir pendant 24 36 he comme je
peux à des moments pendant il y a une
période la première semaine 2è semaine
de la 4e manche, j'avais rien à faire.
C'était hyper perturbant. On était tout
le temps sur le même bord. Le le vent
était toujours le même, le bateau il
roulait, il y avait juste des petits
ajustements en faire. Je jeis pas à
grand-chose. Mais en fait, mon job aussi
quand il est bien fait, c'estàd que j'ai
plus rien à faire. C'est que comme je
délègue et je j'essaie de déléguer un
maximum, de responsabiliser un maximum
mon équipage, du coup, au bout d'un
moment,
je considère que j'ai bien fait quand
j'ai plus rien à faire. on va dire dans
les dans les équipages professionnels,
dans les pilotes de courses, h quand ils
vont au solaire ou quand ils vont se
tirer la bour, est-ce qu'il y a des
phénomènes de dopage ? Non, pas en
bateau, franchement, il y a pas de
café à Ouais, salle café, ouais, des
techniques de sophrologie, de
méditation, d'étirement, ouais,
beaucoup. Mais le dopage puis il y en a
enfin je veux dire il y a des tests sur
qui sont faits au hasard en général sur
les trois premiers et puis après
d'autres dans les dans les courses euh
mais non non sont des athlètes de haut
niveau et euh et qui sont
déjà quand tu vois le le la durée de vie
de en tant qu'athlète euh tu Jean le Cam
il a passé 65 un truc dans ce goûl quoi
et il y en a plein qui vont qui vont
continuer comme ça en fait C'estàd qu'il
y a une grosse prépa mentale, il y a une
grosse prépa physique. C'est des
personnes qui font plein de sports
variés tout au long de l'année. En plus
d'être chef d'entreprise et de gérer les
équipes et voilà.
l'équitation et le et la voile, c'est
les deux seuls sports mixtes déjà, enfin
sport olympique parce que la mécanique
n'est pas olympique. Euh mais c'est les
deux seuls sports où tu as des où le le
sportif doit être athlète de très haut
niveau et en même temps chef
d'entreprise avec des des charges
énormes quoi. C'est un bateau, ça coûte
quelques millions quand même, même
plusieurs millions pour ceux du vent des
globes.
Euh et alors le prix des chevaux
Ah le prix des chevaux ou c'est c'est
Ouais. Donc
c'est un système parce qu'en plus le
prix des chevaux tu as le cheval mais en
plus tu as la structure. Il faut que tu
es un manège, les écuries, le camion
pour partir en concours. Tu as très peu
de sponsors, c'est en général des
propriétaires qui te font confiance et
il y a qu'une durée de vie en plus pour
un cheval. Et puis en plus, tu peux
tomber sur un super craque, être
toi-même un super cavalier et ne jamais
et ne et que ça marche pas parce que tu
enfin il y a un moment c'est deux êtres
humains enfin deux êtres vivants qui qui
communiquent. Donc c'est compliqué comme
sport quoi quand tu es athlète. C'est il
faut vraiment avoir des business plans
et sérieuse tu es pas que sportif quoi.
Faut en avoir dans la tête. Ah mais tu
as plein de très très bons marins qui
iront jamais faire le vent des globes
parce que ils vont ils ils peuvent pas
ils savent pas forcément où ils sont pas
juste doués ou aptes où ils ont pas
envie euh d'être en plus chef
d'entreprise, de gérer une équipe,
monter une équipe, faire les médias,
faire la com, faire prendre des risques
financiers dingues. Est-ce que tu es
propriétaire du bateau ou pas
propriétaire du bateau ? Est-ce que tu
es propriétaire du bateau ? ton ton
sponsor te lâche, tu te retrouves avec
le bateau sur les bras qui a des minions
euh ou tu es pas propriétaire et en fait
du coup bah le sponsor il décide de te
dégager, tu te retrouves sans rien. Ah
c'est compliqué, c'est des il y a un
stress il y a un stress qui est très
très lourd et quand tu pars en équipage,
tu as en plus pour répondre à ta
première question la grande la grande
frayeur parce que en solitaire tu as que
toi, tu as que ta pomme. En équipage,
faut que tu ramènes tout le monde et ça
le jour du départ sur lesquet
tu as la famille qui vient de voir qui
dis vous me le ramenez hein.
Tu as le droit à combien de pourcentage
de perte ?
J'ai pas fait j'ai pas vu ça dans dans
le même sens. J'ai plutôt je leur ai
toujours dit par contre qu'il y avait 11
combinaisons de survie et 11 places dans
les radeaux même si on était 12 et que
comme ça ça mettait un petit peu de
piment en cadeau. Tu vois
une tiroir de sort.
Je je reviens juste une seconde sur le
dopage. Est-ce que tu penses qu'il
faudrait faire des tests inopinés à nos
hommes politiques ? Sont censé être des
athlètes de haut niveau ? Ils sont
censés être des athlètes de haut niveau.
Ah bah non, dans leur tête. Dans leur
tête. Ouais, je j'aurais pas dit ça.
J'aurais bien aimé moi avoir des grands
exemples.
Euh je pense qu'on a on a plus de
repères, on a plus de grandes personnes
inspirantes, tu vois. Enfin, je sais
pas, j'ai 41 ans, euh j'ai jamais voté
pour quelqu'un. J'ai jamais eu cette
envie cette dis vraiment de dire "Ah là
ouais, je vais voter."
Et je trouve qu'il y a de faut vraiment
chercher maintenant pour trouver je
trouve quelqu'un de vraiment inspirant
avec
quand tu lis les
Joy Star avait fait ça un moment
s'appelait éloquence à l'assemblée où il
y avait les grandes de l'Assemblée
nationale quand tu voyais la qualité du
discours à l'époque
de maintenant tu dis qu'il s'est passé
quelque chose quand même. On a les
politiques qu'on mérite.
Ouais. Alors ça de l'œuf ou la poule
qui a commencé ? Est-ce que est-ce qu'on
est-ce que c'est ça ou est-ce que c'est
faut prendre le problème à l'inverse ?
Ça je saurais pas dire. Quand on est
skipeur, on dit skiper ou skipeuse ?
Alors moi perso, je déteste skipe il y
en a un l'autre jour qui m'a qui m'a qui
m'a dit skipè, j'ai cru que j'allais
l'emplater. Skipète ? Ouais, c'était
affreux.
Euh pour moi le problème se pose pas
parce que je suis on est en France et
que je manager un équipage, je dirige un
équipage donc moi je suis capitaine.
Voilà, je ça je suis enfinitait.
Donc là je suis plutôt assez contente
là-dessus. Mais non ben non, c'est
skipper quoi. Mais ça reste un mot
anglais. Donc pourquoi est-ce qu'on
irait le le
tu vois le traduire ? Quand on dit
skipper comme toi, femme endurcie,
affuté avec de l'expérience, chef
d'entreprise qui doit jongler de tout
partout. Ah ! Quel conseil tu peux
donner aux chefs d'entreprise, aux
entrepreneurs,
aux jeunes ? On n'est pas à la fin de
l'interview hein. Très dur,
je sais pas. Tu as des trucs à à
transmettre. Non, tu gères des hommes
dans un milieu confiné ou tu gères des
hommes et des femmes ? Ouais, c'est ce
qui Mais c'est c'est ce que je me dis
dans mes conférences quand je commence,
je leur disf en gros que moi je vais
raconter une histoire mais je sais pas
comment tu vois diriger une grande
entreprise en éolien ou en ce que tu
veux.
euh ni euh ce qu'est une vie de bureau
ou être sédentaire ou quoi que ce soit,
mais par contre gérer un projet, monter
des projets et ça, on sait le faire.
Donc en mais avec tout plein de valeur.
Donc pour moi, je leur dis c'est un
buffet, venez piquer chez nous, je vais
pas vous apprendre votre métier, vous
allez pas apprendre le mien. Mais par
contre, il y a des échanges à faire et
c'est dans la ce qui m'intéresse c'est
la dans tout en fait, c'est la
complémentarité, c'est le mélange
d'expérience. J'ai la chance d'avoir des
partenaires qui m'ont beaucoup aidé sur
cette sur cette aventure
euh et notamment pour pour recruter mon
équipage euh parce que ça a jamais été
avec mes partenaires, tiens, je te donne
du pognon et vas-y quoi. C'est au
contraire, c'était derrière beaucoup
plus d'humain, beaucoup de retour. Moi,
je pouvais vachement parler avec les
commerciaux comme ils m'ont montré, tuis
les méthodes disque par exemple, tu où
tu peux lire les les personnes en cas de
couleur et que derrière ça te donne des
plein de clés, de plein de trucs, enfin
voilà, des des trucs de de DRH ou et moi
du coup je leur amène une autre
expérience. Et quelle couleur toi ? Bah
moi je suis rouge hein. Ça c'est très
très rouge. Après violet, il y a du
jaune ? Non non, après c'est vert et
jaune execo et bleu en dernier quoi. Moi
la partie analytique chez moi c'est un
peu un peu la dernière. Et rouge c'est
quoi ? Euh bah plutôt leader,
compétition dominant, enfin vert qui va
plutôt rechercher l'harmonie. Euh jaune,
c'est les petits soleil quoi. Problème
si tu as que des jaunes à bord, tu fais
la fête tout le temps, ça marche pas. Si
tu as que des bleus, tu sors pas du port
parce que si tu as une table, une vis
qui manque sur la table à carte, on va
couler.
Et voilà, enfin c'est c'est hyper
intéressant de pouvoir lire après les
gens, je trouve, de cette façon-là. Et
moi, en tout cas, pour moi, ça m'a
vachement aidé. Donc, j'ai pas Ouais. de
de leçon ni de conseil ni quoi que ce
soit. Je préfère avoir euh puis ouais,
je suis encore toute jeune entre
guillemets, je fais pas mal de trucs
mais encore
20 ans 30 ans minimum je pense à rouler
ma bosse. Donc
mais des partages d'expérience et et ça
c'est intéressant à faire je trouve.
Ouais, beaucoup plus. Tuèes combien de
kilos de
nourriture ? C'est de la nourriture
moitié moitié. Non, nous on était que en
frais. Euh la viande était apertisée,
c'estàd remis sous vide et puis très
lentement.
Euh j'ai la chance d'avoir un bon copain
qui s'appelle Éric au hospital et qui du
coup au départ nous avait donné deux
énormes jambons sur
et ça ça a été en fait nous on n pas
d'alcool à bord, c'est bateau sec, c'est
la moindre goutte d'alcool, même une
bière change tes perception et donc ça
je refuse catégoriquement qu'il y ait de
l'alcool à bord. Par contre, se faire
des petits apéros, tu sais, pour fêter
l'ami parcours ou un joli coucher de
soleil ou tu sais, un moment petit
fédérateur entre nous parce que 40
jours, c'est long quand même, tuas 5
semaines, c'est euh et tu as besoin de
petits moments et euh donc ça, il y
avait plein on avait un peu de soft et
puis a un truc qui marche bien, c'est
quand même de l'eau avec du avec un
morceau de citron et un peu de sucre, ça
remplace les typonches he tu fais des
typonches pour enfant et donc ouais,
c'est un peu ça. Et du coup, on avait
les jambons d'Éric au hospital pour ça
euh soit en chiffonate, soit dans les
carbonaraas parce que le samedi c'était
carbo. C'était ça c'était notre une de
notre addition. Et non, le reste on
mangeait assez bien. Quoi ? Je préférais
comme le le la nourriture c'est du poids
qui va s'évacuer au fur et à mesure, je
préférais avoir
mettre de l'argent parce que ça coûte
cher he les tout ce qui est liophilisé.
Je préférais payer une personne pour ça,
ma chef qui était aussi marin et payer
en plus de la nourriture mais garder ce
moment fédérateur autour de la
nourriture quoi. Et comme ça, tu avais
sur les 12 en général au repas, on est 9
10. Il y a toujours un ou deux qui
viennent de se coucher qui voilà. Mais
dès qu' dès qu'elle prenait le tiroir où
il y a les fourchettes dedans et qu'elle
faisait comme ça, tu avais tout le monde
qui sortait
des qui sortaient des sacs de couchage
et même si tu vas me bouffer des fois en
sac de couchage parce que tu as froid et
que des iceberg là. Euh non, on n pas
trord. Non non, nous on est passé trop
nord. Là, les l'organisateur de la
course mettait des waypoints pour pas
qu'on aille trop bas. Et sur toutes les
courses maintenant, à part le Julver, tu
les recevais comment ? On les avait au
départ de la course, de la part de la
Manche. On avait un parcours
obligatoire.
Euhh,
il y a que le Jul Verne où tu peux
vraiment avoir où là c'est le tour du
monde où tu vas le plus vite possible
euh avec un départ quand tu veux, c'est
un record, c'est pas une course. Et là,
tu fais le tour de la planète le plus
vite possible. Il y a que là où tu peux
aller vraiment sud. Maintenant la marine
australienne en a eu un peu marre
d'aller secourir
et puis la marine chilienne aussi. Donc
les deux ont dit vous calmez un peu le
jeu sinon tout le monde continue de
descendre le plus bas, le plus bas, le
plus bas possible.
Et donc maintenant, il y a quand même
pas mal de de zones de glace, on va
dire, définies pour pas qu'on aille
faire trop les malins.
Quand tu rentres, le bateau, tu le mets
à la révision, tu mets ton équipage à la
révision, tu te mets à la révision.
Ouais. Ouais. On n pas des machines he
puis même mes machines l' en révision.
Donc
Tixi s'est rentré en très bon état. Euh
je le sors de l'eau là. Je dis cette
année, il naviguera pas je pense euh
parce que si pour naviguer ça coûte de
l'argent rien coûte parce là rien que
pour sortir le bateau de l'eau, j'en ai
pour un peu moins de 10000 € là à peu
près tu essay là déjà juste sortir le
bateau de l'eau 4 jours le mettre sur
les ber faire un antioling le remettre à
l'eau. En c'est c'est coup de carer et
passer un film de peinture protecteur
sur le bateau. Euh ouais ça doit me
coûter je crois l'un dans l'autre entre
la manutention tout ça. Je dois tourner
à 8005 ou un 8005 ou 9000 un truc dans
ce goûl. Donc faut les trouver hein
déjàin. C'est pas c'est pas le c'est
comment pour les trouver prostitution ?
Non non non non
euh non. Ben je là je des partenaires.
Enfin je suis un peu entre deux là. Je
suis en train de recréer un nouveau
projet et je suis sur les fins de tiro
un autre projet. Donc c'est pour ça
l'année dernière, j'étais pas en état de
trouver de l'argent au mois de septembre
pour aller naviguer cette année avec le
bateau, recréer un projet et repartir.
Il fallait que j'ai un j'étais
mentalement j'étais incapable, c'était
pas possible. Donc j'ai pas cherché
d'argent. De toute manière, on a fait
plus de 48000 en 2 ans. Ça fait depuis
2018 que je navigue avec le bateau qu'on
règle sur l'Atlantique en long large
travers, voir le monde. Ouais, il peut
s'il navigue pas pendant un ou 2 ans, il
va il ira très bien, il y a pas de
souci. Donc euh très simplement, il
reste cette année au la cité de la
voile. Si je trouve de quoi faire le le
pilote de mon prochain projet au mois
d'août ou septembre, j'irai le faire
mais c'est pas la priorité quoi. Je j'ai
d'autres priorités maintenant. Il y a ce
qui est important et ce qui est urgent
quoi. C'est quoi l'académie Tabarli ?
Bah, c'est le prochain projet de
J'aimerais euh j'ai toujours eu cette
ce truc de vouloir que les bateaux
soient avoir assuré un avenir pour eux
pérennes financièrement euh qui qui me
survivent aussi et et qui soient utile.
Et je pense qu'en ce moment euh on a
besoin d'aventure humaine en fait, de
passer du temps ensemble, que d'être des
êtres humains fassent des projets
ensemble et qu'on et qu'on passe du
temps et pour ça la montagne et euh et
la voile sont deux éléments euh
particulièrement propices à ça, quoi.
Et sauf qu'en ce moment en montagne
comme je passe pas mal de temps en
montagne
dans ces deux environnements là les deux
bah tu te retrouver avec des marins qui
sont de moins en moins bons et des
skilleurs qui sont de moins en moins bon
fait sur la semaine de ski maintenant
par exemple tu prends je sais pas une
semaine dans la vallée de Cham bah tu
vas skier une journée, tu vas aller une
je une journée à Genève une journée dans
dans les termes machin tu retournes qui
est enfin après on va dire ouais ouais
mais ça coûte cher de ce qui est Oui ça
coûte cher et le bateau aussi ça coûte
cher mais ça a toujours coûté cher. Donc
en fait c'est pas ça problème c'est à
côté où il y a maintenant tellement de
sollicitation c'est devenu tellement
compliqué il y a tellement en plus de
demandes et d'offres et de que ben l'un
dans l'autre
et il y a plein de bateaux où bah
souvent tu as des tu as des bateaux de
famille et les enfants adorent naviguer
sur leur bateau des parents mais ils
disent bah moi une fois que les parents
sont morts je vends le bateau quoi.
c'est trop compliqué, c'est trop
d'argent et puis faut appeler les
copains, faut générer, faut manager tout
ça et et c'est comme les châteaux.
Ouais, moindre mesure pour les bateaux
de plaisance, tout le monde n'a pas
hérité de de ménir comme comme moi j'ai.
Mais euh
et en fait les plaisanciers sont un peu
les sentinelles de de des océans en
fait. C'est eux qui vont sur l'eau,
c'est eux qui vont voir un peu tout ce
qui se passe et ça fait vivre plein de
corps de métier, plein de plein de
toutes les petites flottes de bateau en
bois, tous les synagogues tout ça c'est
c'est un patrimoine incroyable en fait.
On a des on a des côtes et des mers et
des ports et sauf qu'on a des bateaux
qui sortent quasiment plus des ports en
fait beaucoup. dans dans il y a un taux
il y a tout un système qui est qui est
sur un peu un peu en bascule et je pense
qu'on peut vraiment inventer une pas pas
moi mais je veux dire on collectivement
entre les associations les euh aller sur
une plaisance comment créer une
plaisance un peu plus durable des
chiffres concernant le la la plaisance
en terme de d'effondrement économique ou
de Non je pas chi je suis très mauvaise
en plus avec les chiffres les retiens et
puis après je les ressors. Et je les
moments dès que je vois mais même sur
mon propre bateau, c'est d je prends la
décision, ouais, j'ai uncune et puis
après je passe à autre chose et je
libère de l'espace. Euh mais je pense
que le taux de sortie annuel en France,
je sais plus, c'est c'est il est
tellement alarmant que je me plante à
chaque fois entre 3h et 3 jours, mais
c'est rien. C'est la moyenne nationale,
elle est elle est très très basse. Perd
un savoir. Ouais, probablement. Mais
c'est surtout un état d'esprit quoi.
C'est euh le le savoir, il peut toujours
se réapprendre mais c'est sûr que il y a
l'état d'esprit puis il y a la volonté
et forcément maintenant surtout que
c'est tu prends du temps, ça met du
temps à connaître l'océan, à savoir
comment est-ce que ça fonctionne. Euh
c'est il faut une vie, c'est comme un
cheval, il faut une vie pour apprendre
quoi.
même au bout d'une vie, tu n'en fais que
que effleurer à peu près le
donc je me suis dit que il manquait un
centre
qui fasse un peu référence dans parce
qu' il y a plusieurs problèmes par aussi
un autre problème c'est qu'il y a aucun
diplôme de reconnu euh tu peux en France
moi je suis capitaine d'un bateau qui
fait 22 m25 j'ai aucun diplôme quand
même. J'ai pas besoin. Tu as pas de
permis au turier ? B, j'ai un permis
bateau mais je suis pas à la je suis pas
au commerce, j'ai pas besoin d'avoir un
diplôme. Et tu dis en fait quand tu dois
aller louer un bateau à l'étranger, il
te demande un diplôme qu'en France on n
pas en fait. Et euh et ça je pense qu'on
il y a pas mal de choses et puis il y a
plein de plaisanciers en fait qui
veulent louer des bateaux ou faire des
tours de l'Atlantique ou euh tu vois
faire mener leur propre expérience de
euh de de voyage en famille ou euh et
puis souvent ils se font peur, ils
revendent le bateau de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique parce que ils sont fait
peur ou enfin il y a plein plein de
choses qui font dans ma tête. Je me suis
dit si on crée un centre euh évidemment
à l'Orient parce qu'il y a déjà la cité
de la voile Éric Tabarli à l'Orient que
mes bateaux sont à l'Orient que euh je
suis censé je vis dans le finistère
c'est
mais mais l'Orient hein non je bougerai
jamais du ministère euh mais pour les
bateaux l'orient c'est la place parfaite
pour eux et je m'étais dit si on crée
une académie ou à terre euh dans des
dans des locaux tu vois c'est comme
comme il
à cheval, tu vois. Mais apprendre
comment réparer tes voiles, comme le
leadership, parce que bon, partir avec
un équipage, surtout quand c'est des
copain, ça s'improvise pas. Si tu veux
que ce soit encore des copains quand tu
débarques, il y a quand même quelques
règles. Survie, sécurité en mer, la
gestion de la faune, de la flore, la
comment est-ce que si tu rencontres des
cachalot, des dauphins, des machins quel
comportement.
C'est enfin, tu vois, il y a il y a
plein de trucs dans la mécanique
hydraulique, il y a le la gestion du
grément. Là, il y a il y a tout plein de
trucs de fondamentaux à pouvoir
apprendre à terre et après aller
apprivoiser le large, appréhender le
large et donc ça en plus pendateau
pour ça. Et donc ça, j'ai vraiment envie
de pouvoir c'est encore en lesuche et je
suis en train d'apprendre comment créer,
tu sais, il faudrait un livre, tu sais,
comment créer une académie pour les nuls
quoi parce qu'à chaque fois je passe sur
un autre sujet, je pars sur un autre, je
d'accord donc la forme juridique, on
peut faire ça. Super.
Donc là, je suis en train de de mettre à
plat toute la nébuleuse à laquelle je
pense et j'aimerais vraiment pouvoir que
faire en sorte qu'il y ait un mouvement
assez fédérateur entre tous les
plaisanciers de que ce soit aussi une un
incubateur de projet plaisance, tu vois,
de de pouvoir avoir des plaisanciers qui
viennent et qu'on puisse accompagner euh
que ce soit économiquement,
juridiquement, donner des bons conseils,
dire "OK, ce chantier-là il est bien là,
le devis c'est pas normal, là tu peux
aller faire ça, ça tu peux faire ça." de
les mettre en réseau, utiliser eux,
l'académie, les locaux pour réparer
leurs bateaux, tu vois qui que bon bah
autant partager la ressource, le
matériel, les les enfin le tout ce qui
va être mécanique, outil euh et ouais,
il y a plein de plein de choses comme ça
que j'aimerais pouvoir mettre en place.
Maintenant, j'ai ce qui est bien, c'est
que j'ai pas de d'échéance de temps.
J'ai pas une deadline. C'est la première
fois depuis très longtemps que j'ai pas
un départ de course ou un départ d'exp
ou un truc. Donc les places sont très
très chères à l'Orient. Donc avant de
trouver bah non mais c'est la sailing
valet maintenant donc c'est comme ça
qu'on appelle c'est puis il y a tous les
teams les très grands teams comme les
gitana B pop tu très grands bateaux et
des très grands hangars et et puis après
tu as les tous les classes 40 qui sont
là les IMO il y a beaucoup de mini il y
a il y a tous les fournisseurs.
Donc la cité de la voile c'est un
bâtiment qui est fini qui peut pas
s'étendre donc pour l'instant je suis en
train de scanner de voir où sont les
options. Est-ce que là on peut
reconstruire quelque chose ou pas ? Donc
c'est j'ai pas encore de business plan
parce que du coup ça va dépendre est-ce
que on reconstruit ? Est-ce qu'on loue,
est-ce que est-ce que quelqu'un va nous
dire "Eh, j'ai des locaux, ça fait 500
m², est-ce que tu les veux ?" Ah ouais,
merci.
Je sais pas.
Donc euh ouais, je sais pas. On va Je
suis je sais que le projet verra le
jour, c'est il y a on est déjà soutenu
par L au club de Monaco, on est soutenu
par L au Club de France.
Il y a plein de de soutiens qui viennent
au fur et à mesure. Euh
et voilà, on va je pense qu'il y a un
c'est mon père a été un peu je trouve le
un peu le le père de quasiment toute la
plaisance en fait. C'est donc je vois je
trouve que recréer quelque chose qui
puisse fédérer un peu tous les tous les
plaisanciers, mettre tout en lien toutes
les associations. Enfin, tu vas faire en
sorte que les Français ne tournent pas
le dos au large et surtout qu'il
puissent vraiment faire des une aventure
entre eux, des petits morceaux chacun à
son à son niveau. Si ça se trouve c'est
une aventure d'une journée pour aller au
glénant, si se trouve c'est aller faire
un tour de l'Atlantique ou plus loin ou
mais il y a beaucoup d'histoires de
belles histoires à écrire sur l'eau
quoi. Et euh
et comme on va pas forcément vers une
génération
très intelligente,
tu sais ça,
on est en train de de s'abrutir. Enfin,
on est on est en train de vraiment de
s'abrutir, je trouve quoi. C'est ça pas
TikTok quand tu es sur ton bateau. J'ai
pas TikTok,
j'ai Instagram, c'est déjà bien. Je Et
puis je vu le peu de trucs que je poste,
j'aime ce côté des réseaux où tu peux
partager des choses où tu vois là quand
les gens nous disent qu'ils ont qui ont
du sens. Mais non, mais quand tu je suis
quand quand les gens me disent qu'ils
ont suivi le tour du monde et qu'ils ont
suivi, j'ai l'impression d'être vendeuse
de rêve et je trouve ça génial. Enfin au
beau sens du terme, tu vois, pas je
vends du rêve, je t'en fume, c'est juste
l'ubuité. Non mais tout commence par un
rêve en fait pour moi. Tu peux pas après
tu rajoutes, tu vois du du travail, de
la persévérance, du temps, tout ce que
tu veux. Mais mais si tu as pas le rêve
au départ, tu vas pas loin dans ta vie.
En fait, je connais la fin du poème le
renoncement de Saint-Pierre. Non. Moi,
je sortirai de ce monde où l'action
n'est pas sœur du rêve. Waouh ! J'aime
beaucoup. J'aime vraiment beaucoup. Faud
que je la note après. Ce sera bien dans
ma confe celle-là. Merci. C'est Jacques
Blamon qui me disait toujours
Ouais si si
c'est ça je ça j'aime beaucoup que
cultiver l'imaginaire pouvoir écrire des
récits et si chacun peut écrire son
récit ça ça m'intéresse. Même sur les
réseaux je montre pas je montre très
enfin je vis dans une super maison enfin
toute petite mais au milieu d'une forêt.
C'est vachement beau. En fait, je je
mets jamais je mettrai ça ça ça je
pourrais pas mettre ça sur sur un sur un
réseau. Enfin, c'est pas hermite
néandertalienne caché dans ta grotte.
Ben en fait c'est déjà oui caché parce
queon m'a suffisamment volé de trucs
pendant toute ma vie. Donc je préfère
quoi ? Comment ?
Écoute, quand tu as les pasadis qui sont
pendant 3 semaines, alors à la mort de
ton père qui essaie de rentrer dans ton
tour maison fusil de chasse. Ouais,
j'avais 13 j'avais 13 14 ans alors je
tirais déjà mais mais voilà, je me suis
dit que si avait les paparas, il y avait
aussi les flics à l'entrée. Donc je me
serais fait je me serais fait avoir. Non
non mais grosselle grosselle.
Non non, il y a plein de il y a plein de
choses où on m'a tuis on te on te prend
en photo tout le temps. C'est pas c'est
une enfance qui était à la fois très
belle et en même temps une
notoriété célébrité je l'ai jamais
demandé en fait. Tu vois tu vis avec tu
grandis avec mais c'est pas un truc qui
quand les gens la recherchent. Moi pour
moi c'est un truc que je comprends pas
quoi parce que quand tu peux pas
influenceuse à Dubaï
avec une bouche en canard du selfie.
Non, j'y arriverai jamais, je pense.
Ce serait très drôle. Mais mais non,
non, je non non, ça ça va pas être
possible. Mais euh
je sais plus où on en était. Ta vie
cachée, nandire ta vie. Ah si un truc
c'est je pense pas enfin si tu veux tu
sais jamais en plus comment ça va être
accueilli et
j'ai il y a des choses où qui peuvent
être peut-être simples
de bonheur très simple et qui vont
provoquer de l'envie chez d'autres
personnes et ça j'ai pas envie quoi en
fait. Euh
et euh et puis même en fait, j'ai pas
envie de dire avec qui où je vais, avec
qui je traîne.
J'ai pas envie de faire un mdropping.
C'est pas parce que la vie privée c'est
sacré. Ouais, mais m même en fait la vie
publique en fait, tu vois même la vie
publique je la mets je la mets très très
peu en fait sur
et j'ai même le je suis pas très bonne
même la promo j'ai repartagé les les
mais j'ai pas tout repartagé tol tous
les trucs les tr quart je ouais bon bah
ça y est c'est fait mais bon bah c'est
moi j'ai pas forcément envie de le
mettre en avant quoi. Mais à des moments
si je peux partager un bon moment,
j'étais sur Pendick enfin à bord
Pendwiick pendant les regates du golf.
Il y a un joli bord à un moment et tu
vois avec le bateau qui est super beau
et là tu prends juste un petit il y a
juste un petit moment puis ouais fait
une story avec parce que ça c'était
vraiment beau que ça amène du rêve et
que que c'est un patrimoine et que ça ça
fait du bonheur aux gens et là ouais il
y a pas de problème mais
montrer e salut aujourd'hui je suis avec
ma triomphe on va faire un va faire de
la moto ouais enfin ça apporte rien au
débat quoi. Ça apporte rien.
Tu t'es renseigné un peu sur la société
de surveillance, comment tu es tracé,
comment Facebook c'est tout de toi,
Google c'est tout de toi, la NSA c'est
tout de toi. H tu tu t'y connais un peu
ou pas du tout ? Je sais que ça existe.
Euh
je me dis que j'ai pas grand-chose à
cacher. Je fais rien d'illégal. J'ai pas
de
Bon bah s'ils veulent savoir, ils ont
qu'à savoir tant qu'ils me font pas suer
en fait. C'est juste laisser mes comptes
tranquilles. J'ai déjà pas beaucoup
d'argent, je suis marin.
Mais euh mais sinon
à part ne rien avoir, je sais pas trop
comment faire en fait. Donc je pense
qu'à partir du je pense que c'était déjà
trop à partir où je l'ai su, je me suis
dit c'est déjà trop tard en fait. Donc
euh à moins de plus avoir euh aucun
réseaux sociaux, ne jamais payant en
carte bleue euh et
de rien faire de Ouais. Sinon en même
temps si c'est vivre
h sera trop tard quoi. Je vois pas
pourquoi s'ils intéresseraient plus à ma
je pense qu'il y a plus intéressant que
que ma pomme à aller chercher à emmerder
quand même. Donc je peux te poser une
question indiscrète ? Bon on verra si je
te réponds ou pas. Ça veut dire quoi ton
tatouage ?
Euh, ça c'est les quatre éléments. Tu as
tu as les Tu es le 5e bien sûr. Non non,
tu as les dents de protection hawaïenne
et puis ensuite c'était les quatre
éléments eau, feu, terre, a Pourquoi ?
Ça me parlait et ça me parle toujours.
Euh esthétiquement, moi je le trouve
assez joli. J'aime bien. Je me suis je
sais pas, je l'ai dessiné un jour et euh
je suis resté là-dessus. C'est très
joli. Merci.
Tu m'as parlé de température létale.
Ouais. Est-ce que tu peux expliquer aux
gens ce que c'est avec le taux
d'humidité et tout ça ? On va arriver à
des 50°gr
des 50°gr.
On vit pas dans ces conditions là. On
développe pas d'agriculture. On vit
enfin Christian Clos, il est en train de
faire un truc qui est pas mal en ce
moment. Il a développé une cabine où tu
peux rentrer dedans et ça te montre ce
qu'est la vie à 50°
et tu te rends compte que tu fais pas
grand-chose si jamais tu as pas avant
conscientisé. Moi j'aime pas le show de
toute manière. Je v en Bretagne, on est
très bien même en Bretagne commence à
faire un peu chaud. Après, il fait super
beau mais ça faut pas trop le dire mais
il fait pas chaud chaud quoi. Après oui,
on peut il va faire enfin c'est c'est
fluctuant évidemment mais j'ai pas le
j'aime l'Écosse, j'aime le Bretagne en
l'hiver, j'aime la montagne. Voilà le
côté créole, je suis je suis métisse
quoi. J'ai vraiment les deux. Le show où
j'ai dès qu'il fait un peu chaud, je
suis très très mal quoi. C'est pas c'est
pas mon truc. Mais elle a dit "Iaginez
ce qui va arriver, j'ai pas besoin de
rentrer dans sa cabine. Je sais déjà que
c'est foutu ou quoi. C'est pas pas
gérable." Quand tu es sur un bateau que
tu te prends un plein cagnard comme ça
et avec pétole que tu peuxer. C'est
l'enfer. C'est l'enfer. C'est l'enfer.
C'est l'enfer. Tu dors pas. Le matelas
il est chaud. Le drap il est chaud. Euh
pendant la journée, tu dors pas en fait
parce que avec un peu de chance, en plus
tu es au vent et au vent bah tu te
prends le soleil. Bon alors là et comme
en plus la température elle monte, enfin
la chaleur monte euh bah voilà tu et
puis quand tu es dès que tu es gité ton
ton but c'est de garder le bateau à
plat. Donc tu vas pas aller
volontairement sous le vent te mettre au
frais qu'en plus donc tu es obligé de
rester en haut où il fait chaud donc tu
dors pas. Euh
le soleil cogne vraiment fort avec la
réverbération. En plus, si tu as un peu
de vent encore, ça passe.
Euh
si tu as pas de vent, là tu pètes un
plomb quoi. Tu pètes un plomb parce
qu'en plus c'est beaucoup contrairement
ce que le les humains terriens, on va
dire peuvent croire, c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de de pas avoir de vent que
d'avoir du vent. Parce que quand tu as
pas de vent, tu avances pas et nous on
peut pas mettre le moteur, on est en
course. Par contre, tu sais pas si
l'autre à côté il avance ou pas. Et donc
chaque risée, tu dois être sur chaque
réglage tout le temps. Alors le poteau
noir par exemple, c'est la zone de
convergence intertropicale. Donc en
gros, tu l'anticyclone des assort qui
tourne dans un sens, l'anticyclone de
Saint-Hélène qui tourne dans le sens
opposé puisque l'autre côté. Donc au
milieu là, tu as une sorte de zone de
frottement là, peau de pu immonde
qui se balade, qui est un très mouvant
qui passe un peu du nord au sud comme ça
là, juste au-dessus de l'équateur avec
des grands grains qui arrivent d'Afrique
et qui traversent
les chiottes du monde. C'est une
horreur. C'est une horreur. Faut pas y
aller. C'est très beau parce que tu as
une lumière incroyable avec puis et tu
te tu te retrouves à un moment avec un
grain mais toi tu vois vraiment bien
rond quoi. Tu vois le truc gris, mais
truc gris ma ventracite truc et tu le
vois avancer comme ça et donc avec un
peu de chance tu peux l'avir. Si tu l'as
pas, bah tu restes pas avancé et puis
lui il passe et quand tu es dedans si
jamais il vient de cueillir alors le
vent il monte McDo donc tout le monde
rentre en manœuvre. Voilà. Mais après,
il faut savoir quand est-ce que tu
quittes le grain parce que si toi tu
veux aller par là mais que le grain lui
il va par là, bah tu
donc il y a un moment Ouais, faut faut
aller faut savoir jusqu'où tu vas et
sans GPS évidemment parce que donc tu
peux pas savoir tuas tu es en train de
calculer à quelle vitesse tu vas, à quel
angle, jusqu'où et après tu te tu en
ressors. Et euh et puis après bah tout
est moite et tu retombes dans cette zone
de chaud en plus ultra humide et puis
vers les voiles qui battent et qui
flappent et la tristitude totale quoi.
Le truc c'est et tu je pète une durite
et tu essayes de à chaque fois de
motiver tous tes barreurs, de rester
hyper concentré. Garder un équipage
motivé, concentré sur des périodes comme
ça, c'est hyper dur en fait de c'est là
où ils ont été formidables. Euh ils étit
sélectionné en fonction des étapes et
ils ont ils ont tout donné à chaque fois
euh surtout dans ces zonesl parce qu'il
savaient que c'était dur quoi. Il y en a
aucun qui s qui se dit c'est en vacances
quoi. Tu peux me faire un peu la lecture
?
C'est-à-dire tu prends ton bouquin, tu
me choisis un passage. Il est de l'autre
côté. Ah ouais ?
C'est pas gentil ça. Qui t'a dit que
j'étais gentil ? H
C'est vrai. Tu as regardé quoi de de
Syerw avant ?
Euh, j'ai regardé quoi ? Euh,
truc sur l'écologie, sur le pétrole.
Ouais.
Guerre pas trop parce que ça me ça me
déprime vraiment beaucoup. Ça déprime
beaucoup de monde en ce moment.
Euh des mouvements euh des des tu sais
des mouvements des gens ou euh politique
quand même pas mal euh
j'ai pas de nom qui me reviennent en
tête comme ça mais euh
des euh j'aime bien après voir des des
des fois tu as des humoristes ou
d'autres gens qui donnent un peu leur
vision, leur truc, ça je regarde pas
mal. Euh la première navigatrice à
passer. Yes ! Euh non, il y a pas mal de
gens en fait. Ça dépend, c'est plus en
fonction du thème et de la thématique
que de la personne que je vais regarder.
Euh puis en fonction de ce que ce à quoi
je je pense à ces momentsl,
fais-moi la lecture. C'est long faire
une lecture. Juste un passage qui te
fait envie ou tu as envie de faire
découvrir.
Bah comme ça, je sais pas qu'en plus j'y
vais page. Ah ouais. Passer avec les
photos.
Euh
ouais, passe une avec les photos, c'est
bon ça. Non, je suis tombé sur une page
où Ouais, j'avais oublié ça. Enfin, pas
oublié mais c'est le cargo. Ouais, il
faudrait faire des avenants au livre.
faudrait vraiment faire des avenants. Il
y a plein de trucs. Bah le typiquement
le le les pêcheurs chinois, j'en ai pas
j'en ai pas parlé et ça ça je suis
dégoûté de pas en avoir parlé quoi.
C'est euh
tu as un dictaphone quand tu es sur ton
bateau. Non, c'est beaucoup plus facile
de par d'écrire quand je suis en là-bas
quand je suis en mer où là bah tu es
coupé de ton téléphone, tu es coupé de
tous ces trucs, tu as le temps, il y a
le sujet qui vient et une fois que ton
ton sujet que tu as ton déroulé
d'histoire, je me mets à à réfléchir un
peu à tout ce que je veux et il y a un
moment je sens que ça doit sortir et du
coup là je sors un premier jet et après
je peux commencer à danser un peu avec
les mots quoi et à choisir vraiment
précisément quel mot je veux mettre où
et puis j'ai le temps en fait mais
souvent C'est ils sont fait mes messages
de bord assez rapidement. À écrire à
terre, c'était beaucoup plus dur en
fait, beaucoup plus dur. Ton livre, il a
été il a été écrit totalement en mer là
? Non non non non. J'ai écris en fait
j'ai pris les messages de bord que j'ai
écrit au
[Musique]
bah pendant les 2 ans. Ouais tous les ce
que j'écrivais déjà. J'ai commencé à
écrire en 2018 sur les premières XP et
là j'ai moi j'ai récupéré à partir de
2020 à peu près 2022 même.
Et je reprends après une fois arrivé,
j'ai repris cela, j'ai repris mon carnet
de bord à moi euh où j'écris à peu près
une fois tous les tr jours. J'avais pas
percuté que j'avais autant écrit en fait
en mer. Et euh après à terre, j'ai dû
refaire le lien entre tout et euh et là
c'était plus difficile parce que c'est
un exercice où tu arrives à 7h, enfin tu
sais, tu te lèves et je suis productive
le matin, donc euh j'ai à 6h 7h tu te
mets sur l'ordi et là c'est sur ton job
quoi. Donc euh il y a des moments, tu
sais que tu dois délivrer quelque chose
et tu y arrives pas, tu as la page
blanche, le truc c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus compliqué en fait. Allez, mais
c'est pas possible d'écrire de lire un
truc comme ça. Tu as besoin de lunettes
? C'est pas ça. C'est pas gentil. Non,
même pas. J'ai une vision de ouf. Ça ça
va, tout va bien.
Je sais pas, c'est toi qui l'allu. Bah
prends. Non, je peux dire des anecdotes
qui sont assez drôles qu'ils sont devant
si tu veux. Allez go. Tu sais, il y a un
truc qui est assez drôle, c'est qu'on
je parce que je tombe dessus et juste
avant c'était encore ça. On croise des
cargos en fait en mer et les cargos on a
le droit de les appeler et comme nous on
a une position estimée
euh c'est bon c'est estimé, c'est par
définition pas très précise, mais on a
le droit d'appeler le cargo dès qu'on le
voit sans savoir comment il s'appelle.
Tu vois, tu les appelles cargos
cargoship. Euh we are sailing vael
pendx. Euh tu t'annonces nous on connaît
pas leur nom évidemment. Euh on navigue
euh à telle direction, on est dans votre
172 par exemple à votre sur votre
tribord de yocopie quoi. 3/4 du temps,
ils répondent. Est-ce que vous nous
recevez ? Ouais. Des tr du temps, ils
répondent. Euh même même plus que les
tris/4 du temps. Sauf que très très
souvent ils se sentent très très seuls.
Et quoi ? Les cargos. Ouais.
Quand tu as une voix de femme, c'est ça
? Ils te font des blagues, ils font euh
"Ouais, ouais. Oh, your lady Captain,
your lady Captain, do you have an
Instagram ?" C'est les tris/4, ils sont
philippins ou asiat ou ils sont tous ou
alors ils sont slaves, ils ont des
accents pas possibles. Et euh du coup
maintenant sur mon Insta, par contre,
j'ai beaucoup de cargot qui me suivent
ou des gens qui
euh Ils sont seuls mais ils
réfléchissent beaucoup. Ouais. Ouais.
Alors, par contre, on a pas du tout la
même vision de l'océan. Euh tuis
l'anecdote sur laquelle je suis tombé
juste après, c'est un cargo qu'on
croise.
Donc on a passé l'équateur mais quand tu
descends donc en gros pour toi l'Europe
est ici, l'Amérique est là, du coup on
Ouais, c'est ça. Du coup, on descend et
en fait, on va contourner l'anticyclone
de Saint-Hélène et on va faire le tour
comme ça pour aller à Capt, on va pas en
ligne droite à Capt
et parce que il y a pas de vent et voilà
quoi. Autant c'est beaucoup plus rapide
de faire un petit détour. Sauf que au
départ bah tant que le vent n'a pas
basculé le long du Brésil, on va vers le
Brésil. Donc on va pas vers Kepterne. Et
quand je leur demande leur position pour
moi calculer la mienne, ça il me la
donne. Après ils me disent "Mais vous
allez où ?" Je ben va à Cap Town. Là il
y a un blanc. Il is not the right
direction. This is not the right
direction. Et le mec il est pas du tout
là. Il est là Ah ouais ouais. Mais là,
il est en panique. Il est complètement
en panique. Il te demande combien tu as
de radeau, combien vous êtes sur place à
bord. Enfin, tu sens que le mec il va
veiller va veiller sur toi. Je dis mais
c'est en fait pour eux mais même quand
certaines fois on leur demandait des
tuis des informations bah justement sur
ce fameux poteau noir, est-ce que parce
qu'il y a des cartes qui sortent ?
Est-ce que vous avez des infos ? Et ils
savent même pas ce que c'est parce qu'on
on eux il ce qu'ils intéressent c'est
les vagues et le courant. Euh nous ça va
être le vent et tout ce qui va se passé.
Et ça, ils ont en fait on était on ne
voit pas la mer du tout de la même façon
quoi. Mais pas du tout. Ils ont une
vision beaucoup plus commerciale.
Ouais. Bah ils ont pas besoin de ça en
fait pour faire avancer leur bateau
quoi, tu vois. Donc eux qui devant ou
pas devant, ils s'en foutent. Ils
mettent les engins et après en fonction,
ils mettent les balasses, les machins.
Non non, ils ont le il y en a plein.
Quand je leur dit, "Vous avez un
forecast, il me dit ouais weather is
good." Je bah ouais le temps est bien,
super mais ça va pas m'aider en fait. Ça
va pas. Ils sont à combien de nœuds eux
? Ils avancent à combien ? 18 20 nœuds
hein en fonction. Après, il y en a qui
sont beaucoup plus lents. Ça dépend ce
qui transporte. Euh s'il y en a qui
remorquent des tu vois, il y en a qui
peuvent il y en a il faut faire gaffe.
Tu les vois puis à quelques milles
derrière, tu vois une plateforme
pétrolière qui est en train d'être
remorquer ou un autre truc. Enfin, il se
passe beaucoup de choses he sur l'eau.
Puis il y en a qui transporte des
matières assez dangereuses.
Il y en a c'est de l'aliment, il y en a
c'est du bétail. Enfin, il y a
Heureusement, il y a enfin il y a un il
y a un les cargos, c'est euh c'est ça vu
des pétroliers fantômes russes. Non, ça
va. Bah après, il y a un il y a un ou
deux bateaux qui nous ont pas répondu
donc bon peut-être. Ilétait des gros.
Ouais. Ouais, des gros. Ouais. Mais bon,
tu des fois ils sont juste pas
endroits où il y a personne. Donc ils
peuvent se permettre enfin en ils
peuvent normalement non, ils se
permettent pas mais il des fois ils
baissent il baissent ils baissent un peu
la veille des fois il
voilà. Tu as pas vu des gros car des
gros cargos ou des pétroliers qui qui
nettoyaient leurs soutes ou qui
nettoyaient leurs cuves ? Non non ça
j'ai pas vu. Tu as pas vu des nappes de
pétrole dans l'eau ? Heureusement non.
Non non, c'est mais après l'océan est
très grand. Je dis pas que ça existe
pas, c'est juste nous on n pas tourné
dessus. Tu me fais la lecture. Tu as vu,
j'avais réussi à bien bien esquiver le
truc.
Et c'est c'est pas possible de faire une
lecture comme ça. Tu es toujours timide
comme ça. Ben non, mais je trouve que
Oui, enfin je sais pas.
Non mais en plus je fais des lectures.
J'ai fait des lectures du de certains de
certains des passages au théâtre.
Mais euh
comment ça au théâtre ? Bah ouais,
j'aime bien. Voilà, je suis bien sortie
de ma zone de confort, on va dire. B me
proposé de lire les messages. J'avais
pas encore écrit le livre. J' c en
novembre l'année dernière. Le théâtre de
l'Orient m'a proposé de lire des
certains de mes textes bah sur scène et
donc j'étais avec mon ami Stan Léverber
qui lui avait du coup lu euh prenait le
contrepied de certains de mes de mes
messages avec des textes d'Éric et on se
faisait ton père. Ouais. Et euh du coup,
c'était 20 % lui, 80 % mes textes à peu
près. Et puis euh donc c'était assez
drôle, on était juste tous les deux sur
scène avec deux grands speed derrière
nous avec des vidéos en plus euh pour
des fois illustrer un peu plus et euh et
non, c'était top. C'était sympa la salle
était pleine. C'est un très beau théâtre
en plus à l'Orient. Personne qui a voulu
être remboursé, pas de jet tomate, rien.
Donc euh Mais non, c'était chouette.
C'était super chouette.
Allez, je t'écoute.
Mais c'est horrible parce que tu peux
pas lire comme ça. Non mais je vais t'
je vais vraiment t'embêter, tu vas voir.
J'ai pas de morceaux. Mais non, parce
qu'en plus à ce moment-là, on part sur
un texte, on part sur minimum 5 minutes
de lecture. J'aime pas faire un tout
petit peu texte. Ça veut dire qu'il
faudrait couper en fait et je serais pas
juste coupé.
Et euh c'est un peu compliqué quoi.
Quand tu quand tu t'as proposé ton
livre, on te l'a réclamé ou c'est toi
qui l'a proposé ? Euh avant de partir au
tour du monde, j'avais cinq ou six
propositions de maison. J'étais c'était
mais moi j'avais pas envie d'écrire un
livre. Ça m'impressionnait vachement
d'écrire un livre. Non, c'est régalé
hein. Merci.
J'ai euh j'ai jamais voulu euh
euh je suis pas écrivaine, j'ai pas
enfin c'est je trouve ça terrifiant.
Puis je voulais pas que ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre qui écrive pour moi.
Euh parce que j'adore écrire ça. Par
contre, c'est un exercice qui me plaît
beaucoup.
Mais euh voilà, tu as quand même un peu
des nick quoi. Ouais. Ah ouais, ouais.
Après, bon benah après maintenant que
les g j'ai j'ai pas la flip sur les
critiques pour le coup parce que j'ai
fait je sais que j'ai fait du mieux que
je pouvais euh
en plein burnout.
J'écrirai probablement pas le même livre
maintenant mais et que j'ai fait du
mieux que je pouvais et que bah
maintenant si quelqu'un
bah oui ok bah fait mieux il y a pas de
problème quoi. On s'est régalé, on s'est
vo on a voyagé, on a appris plein de
trucs, on a appris des trucs sur toi, on
a appris euh franchement euh
les petites photos, est-ce que tu peux
les montrer
au moins une ?
Euh, montre-moi la couverture.
Ça c'est une super couverture. C'est en
fait, c'est hyper dur de trouver une
photo où tu peux voir Pendxis et moi en
même temps.
Et ça c'est mon ami Guillaume Plisson
qui a avec qui j'aime beaucoup faire des
photos parce que lui il me demande pas
de poser au moins donc c'est bien et il
arrive à saisir des bons instants.
Après toutes les photos quasiment moi
j'ai réussi à disparaître quasiment
toutes les photos. Bah oui, tu as vu
qu'il y en a pas. Il y en a une c'est
tout.
Remontre-moi la couverture que mon réal
puisse te cadrer. Ah, ce beau petit cul
de Pandwix quand même.
C'est vrai, il a un joli petit cul. On
appelle ça comme ça.
Euh non, c'était chouette. Bah à
l'intérieur, tuas tu peux voir il y a
une photo de du
des cartes isobariques avec lesquelles
on travaillait où là tu vois que ça reçu
à la Blu. Ouais, ça un gamin à la old
school. un gamin de 4 ans. Celle-là, je
l'aime vraiment beaucoup parce que tuas
ça c'est mon second Tom. Reste bouge
pas. Tu vois la vague qui est derrière
qui est bien balaise et puis lui avec
son petit fleg manglis qui passe. Enfin
c'est c'est un super des bons moments.
Ouais on a passé des bons moments
ensemble. Est-ce que tuas est-ce que tu
as un sujet que tu souhaiterais aborder
avec nous qu'on a pas abordé ?
Ah je sais pas. et à mon équipage qui
était merveilleux. Il y a
les autres concurrents, il y a je a
parlé aussi. Enfin, je sais pas, c'est
toi qui voit ça. Écoute, ça fait c'est
la première fois que tu fais une
interview qui fait 1h25.
Ouais. Tu l'as tu l'as vu passer ou pas
? Non. Ah non non non. Pour une fois, ça
fait du bien de de pas avoir des des
formats courts. Les journalistes quand
ils t'interviewent,
comment tu peux résumer en en 15 minutes
maximum ? Oh, j'y arrive pas et euh j'y
arrive pas et puis c'est souvent des
conditions où je suis pas euh
je j'aime j'aime avoir le temps de
parler, j'aime les silences. Les les
gens n'aiment pas les silences. C'est
puis en fait ce qui ce que je déteste
surtout c'est un c'est la presse écrite
parce que ce que tu dis euh et le plus
souvent mal retranscrit ou alors soit
c'est retranscrit comme tuas comme quand
tu as parlé, sauf que tu ne n'écris pas
comme tu parles.
Et ce qui m'a vraiment terrifié cette
année, c'est que en arrivant avec
un tour un tour du monde,
une aventure humaine incroyable, un
équipage qui il y a leur nom à la fin du
livre, on est resté 2 ans sans sanguer,
il y a pas eu une engueulade sur le
bateau et si tu me crois pas, tu les
appelles. C'est c'est juste on s'est
régalé et on a il y a il y a du la
campagne de sélection, le recrutement,
les entraînements, tous ils ont été des
merveilleux, enfin des êtres humains.
C'était on a été touchés par la grâce
quoi. vraiment on a vraiment eu de la
chance quoi de de de bon ça a été du
travail he d'entraîner de fédérer tout
le monde évidemment mais mais c'est
c'est
enfin je les aime c'est ils sont ils
sont ils sont formidables et tu pars
faire une belle aventure sans satellite
différente. a pas une grande couverture
médiatique parce que c'est pas une
course qui est très médiatique mais 2
les sur les réseaux on a on a super bien
marché avec un énorme temps d'engagement
enfin tout va bien il y a plein de
choses à raconter et les 95 % du temps
on va dire tu t'es ramené à ta condition
de fille de
de plein de trucs et là moi c'est ça me
touche pas parce que je sais qui je suis
ça enfin ça me touche plus on va dire
maintenant il y a pas de le syndrome de
l'imposteur mais bah d'imposteur Je sais
pas mais c'est très dur c'est dur quand
on te regarde toujours par ce prisme là
alors que tu fais plein d'autres trucs
parti avec my corn en Mongolie on a fait
plein de choses enfin genre j'ai un
parcours assez riche maintenant tu es
ramené à ça donc en fait que tu fasses
ça ou tu es rien en fait tu n'es rien
donc on te par on te dit en permanence
que tu n'es rien et là quand cette année
je me suis dit mais avec si je vous
amène autant de contenu
euh vous le prenez pas vous venez pas me
voir si ça vous intéresse pas moi il y
aura pas de problème enfin C'est on
n'est pas obligé d'être intéressé par
ça. Mais comment est-ce que vous traitez
le reste de l'actualité ? Alors parce
qu'ici si moi je vous amène tout ça et
que vous êtes vous le traitez par vous
ce que vous voulez, comment est-ce que
le reste de l'actualité vous le traitez
? Et du coup, ouais, quel problème enfin
les problèmes qui sont monstrueux
maintenant dans moi je pense que dans 5
ans on se prend bon les guerres
économiqu on les a déjà de ressources
comme tu dis on les a déjà aussi l'IA on
va en perdre le contrôle puis après on a
les problèmes environnementaux perm
ça va être sympa mais ouais enfin
comment est-ce que vous le traitez en
fait tout ça et plus en plus tout le
reste de l'actualité en plus
c'est quoi votre prisme
Pourquoi ? Il est où votre métier ? Bon
après dans le tas évidemment il y en a
qui ont fait du très bon boulot. Il y en
a avec qui je me suis régalé.
Je elle s'appelait Lodie euh mais je
sais plus pour quelle c'était une radio
euh début d'interview euh ancienne
triathlète mais du coup championne aussi
et et euh et ouais on a fait ça
sacrifice quoi. Ouais, puis on a les
questions étaient intéressantes et puis
puis tu en as d'autres 7h du math
en télé qui première question qui dit
alors 50 ans après votre père ça vous
fait quoi de déjà que mais alors à 7h du
mat faut pas venir me chercher quoi.
Donc là forcément tu mais qu'est-ce que
tu veux que je te dise ? Je veux pas
faire parler les morts. Qu'est-ce que
votre père vous auraient dit ? Mais j'en
sais rien et puis je m'en fous quoi
surtout en fait dire il est mort il y a
27 ans. Je m'en fous pas de mon père
mais c'est juste enfin vous avez pas
autre chose là. Tu sais ce que dit un
philosophe de gauche ? Je crois que
c'est l'ordon.
Le simple et le court c'est le passeport
pour le slogan idéologique pur. Ouais.
Ouais.
Bah
après, je sais pas, peut-être il y a des
choses tout problème bien expliqué peut
être court aussi quoi. Mais il y a un
moment faut savoir résumer les choses
simplement et expliquer simplement les
choses. Mais euh je peux te poser des
questions internet ? Ouais, bien sûr. Je
l'apprends à l'arracher. Quel est
l'avenir de la plaisance selon elle ?
Comment gérer un gros conflit sur un
bateau ?
Euh l'avenir de la plaisance,
honnêtement, je n'en sais rien parce que
ça je pense que ça va être lié tout
comme le course au large, ça va être lié
à
l'avenir du monde. Euh ça va dépendre
quelles vont être les finances des gens
parce que bah ouais, si on a
enfin il y a un moment faut faut payer
les cordages, les moteurs, l'essence et
tous ces trucs là. Donc je sais pas trop
vu le prix des ressources.
Ça va, je pense que ça va être assez
lié. Euh et je suis pas analyste moi
là-dedans, donc je vais pas vous aller
m'aventurer là-dedans, mais je pense
qu'il y aura des façons de s'en sortir.
Mais il va falloir apprendre à bricoler
soi-même. Ouais, je pense beaucoup.
Euh et comment gérer un conflit ? Un
coup de Oui, un coup de winch. Ben
écoute, moi j'en ai pas eu en fait.
J'en ai pas eu et parce qu'on avait mis
un équipage en place où on avait passé
beaucoup de temps ensemble où j'avais
des êtres humains, je dis qui voyaient
les autres pour ce qui était eux-mêmes.
Et du coup, dès qu'il y en avait un qui
était plus fatigué ou bah il se mettait
un peu dans sa bulle, euh d'autres ou
céit un peu ronchon ce qu'on avait tous
des journées ou ou tuas un peu grinche,
euh bah les autres te foutent la paix.
Euh tu sais aussi que tu es ring et tu
te l'assumes et bah tu restes dans ton
coin, tu fais quand même ton taf. Euh et
puis souvent en fait il y en a je il y
en avait un j'avais mes petits soleil
euh tu sais dans dans l'équipage en a
toujours qui sont qui vont toujours
super bien quoi. Et euh en général c'est
ceux qui vont super mal hein. Non non
ils allaient vraiment très très bien
quoi. Mais voilà tu tu arrives toujours
à à envoyer en envoyer un un peu au
charbon pour aller un peu déclencher un
peu le truc et entre eux ils avaient au
contraire beaucoup de dialogue beaucoup
de tolérance beaucoup de respect
d'empathie surtout beaucoup d'empathie.
il comprenait pourquoi est-ce que si un
était pas bien ou alors dans les
conversations parce que c'était même pas
il y avait pas de conflit mais par
contre on a on parlait beaucoup et tu on
parlait de tout pouvait être abordé et
on avait des
bah évidemment des âges différents parce
qu'il y en avait qui avaient 22 23 24
d'autres plus de 50 ans euh des milieux
sociaux différents
des nationalités différentes. Il y avait
pas de religion différente. Bon, après,
il y en avait qui étaient soit até, soit
plutôt chrétien, mais on avait pas de
Non, je crois pas. Euh,
et en fait, tout le monde arrivait à se
mettre à la place de l'autre en disant
"Bon, alors lui, comme il est comme ça,
il peut réfléchir comme ça, donc c'est
normal, donc on va le prendre comme ça
machin." Et puis voilà, en fait, c'est
juste la conversation plutôt que se
heurter à la personne disant "Mais toi,
tu es un con quoi ?" Je crois qu'il
faudrait faire des bateaux comme ça,
récupérer tous les diplomates du monde,
les enfermer pendant 2 ans ? Non. Alors,
les enfermai peut-être pas, mais j'avais
voulu faire ça pendant un moment. Ouais.
Avoir, enfin, c'était un des projets que
j'aurais bien aimé faire, avoir quelques
responsables de politique à bord, des
euh des CO aussi. J'aurais bien aimé
avoir des CO de CAC 40 et tout ça à bord
d'avoir
il y a plein de personnalités comme ça
que j'aurais bien aimé avoir euh juste
pour qu'il se parle en fait parce que tu
peux pas tricher très longtemps et comme
nous on n pas de cabine dans le bateau,
c'est en fait quand tu des petits câlins
y avait une règle, il y avait pas de
coupe à bord donc évidemment il y en a
eu deux des petits câlins sur terre.
Évidemment, on a eu deux, ils sont
toujours ensemble mais ouais, on évite
de on évite d'avoir les couples à bord
quand même parce que sinon tant qu'ils
sont ensemble, ça va. S'il se sépare là,
c'est la galère.
Bah, tu vois, c'est
non. Donc mais non, au contraire, tu
apprends comme tu ne bah tu sais quand
tu rentres dans le bateau donc tu as les
cellules de vie en commun puis après tu
pars dans de ce qu'on appelle des
coursives. Donc c'est deux couloirs. Là,
tu as sep banettes de chaque côté. Donc
euh
et donc tu tu dois te déshabiller devant
les autres, tu dois vivre devant les
autres,
tu vas aux toilettes, voilà, tu partages
à peu près tout. Enfin
et euh donc bah tu traites les autres
comme toi, on a tu as envie qu'on te
traite évidemment. Et c'est là où tu
apprends à avoir même si moi au départ
je suis assez euh solitaire euh en fait
il y en été on était beaucoup comme ça
avoir aimé être tout seul et en fait euh
on adore être en groupe parce que c'est
un groupe qui qui s'adapte en permanence
et vraiment c'était tolérance, empathie,
dialogue, tout ce dont on manque
maintenant dans notre société beaucoup.
Mais euh je pense que tant qu'il y a ça
et que bah tu as du respect, tu as de
l'écoute et euh et comme encore une fois
tu prends les gens comme les chevaux, tu
prends les gens pour ce qu'ils sont
réellement et pas la projection que que
tu as quoi de
question internet. Est-ce que la
déconnexion totale qu'elle a vécu par
période avec cet éloignement de toutes
les mauvaises nouvelles qu'on vit en ce
moment est finalement plutôt une bonne
chose ou une mauvaise ? Est-ce qu'on n'
pas tous besoin de s'éloigner de
l'actualité pour se retrouver nous-même
et s'apaiser ? Ah bah si maintenant il
faut Mais en fait le problème c'est
qu'on a maintenant une un monde qui va
trop vite pour nos petits cerlair
mentale euh dans dans la que ce soit
dans la vie de couple, dans le travail,
dans le les informations du monde
entier, dans les angoisses, de il y a
beaucoup beaucoup trop beaucoup trop et
à chaque fois que j'en parle avec
d'autres marins ou même avec d'autres tu
avec Jéraldine Fasnart par exemple qui a
fait des experts en montagne ou chaque
fois qu'on c'est tout on se dit tout la
même chose quoi. C'est c'est pas nous
qui allons chercher les déconnexions en
fait. On va juste vivre au rythme où on
est censé vivre normalement. C'est là
c'est quand on rentre que c'est plus
normal du tout. Ça va beaucoup beaucoup
trop vite. D'accord ? L'être humain est
intelligent et on peut aller on peut
aller, on peut aller mais en fait on
peut pas aller. On voit toutes les
névroses que ça engendre, on voit tous
les dégâts que ça engendre. Euh c'est
pas je pense pas que ce soit qu'on est
en train de vivre dans notre habitat
naturel, on va dire.
Question internet. Bonjour. Le futur du
secteur industriel de la voile de
plaisance et de course point virgule un
sentiment.
Deuxème question, une clé de lecture
point interrogation. Quelle est votre
impression sur ce monde peu visible du
commun des mortels ? Point
interrogation. Merci.
Bah pareil hein, ça va être en fonction
de l'état du monde, je pense.
Ça tout va dépendre de les de comment il
y a la course au large tout comme la
plaisance font de grands
de essa d'avancer et d'aller vers
quelque chose de mieux. Euh,
tu vois, il ils essayent de recycler les
carbones, ils essayent de recycler les
bateaux, ils essayent d'avoir des des
productions de bateau plus de plus en
plus vert, ils font il y a des
collectifs comme euh l'association la
vague qui essayent de réfléchir à
comment inventer une nouvelle plaisance,
une nouvelle façon de faire de la course
large,
mais euh mais il y a un moment, c'est
quand même le le monde, les finances et
l'état du monde qui vont enfin je pense
décider
Tu peux tu peux faire ce que tu veux. Si
le prix de pétrole il augmente comme ça
et que toutes les ressources elles
augmentent comme ça, il y a un moment on
va avoir un problème. Question internet.
Pour avoir travaillé en réparation de
bateaux de plaisance depuis 22 ans, le
métier se casse la gueule sauf
travailler chez Multiplast. Je connais
pas Multiplast. Ouais, c'est un grand
chantier. Ton projet peut-il remédier à
ça ?
Je sais pas. Non, je pense pas. Euh
malheureusement je peut-être en créant
de nouvelles vocations.
Euh peut-être en créant une nouvelle
vocation. Ouais. Les politiques qui
aident à créer des nouvelles vocations.
Est-ce que la filière de la voile de des
écoles de voile
de l'optimiste, tu as jamais fait
d'optimiste toi ? Non non, je suis pas
passé par le cursus fédéral. Tuas pas
fait de petit bateau. Tu as fait que du
gros bateau direct. Ouais,
malheureusement hein, parce que c'est
pas c'est pas forcément bien mais bon
bah j'ai pas choisi. Donc tu as pas fait
de Newcat 14, de Newcat 16 ? J'ai pas
fait tout ça. J'aurais et franchement ça
m'a manqué hein. Enfin c'est après que
j'ai compris que ça m'a manqué mais j'ai
suivi mon père et je suis directement
allé sur des gros bateaux. Donc ça m'
fait de laser. Non. Oh bah ouais
non plus. Non plus.
Euh
et c'est je dis c'est c'est pas c'est
pas une bonne chose. C'est pas du tout
une bonne chose. Mais bon, c'est comme
ça. Euh
les
Ouais. le le le le la fédération
il y a a mis en place tout un système de
d'école de voile où là tu peux apprendre
à faire de la voile mais jusqu'à tes 16
ans. Après tu es un peu lâché dans la
nature. Après il faut que tu as tu as tu
as des centres de formation un petit peu
à droite à gauche. Euh tu as le CPA, tu
as le CPA, tu as les glénants, tu as
Mais tout ça ça représente quand même un
sacré budget et puis il faut beaucoup de
temps parce que c'est à chaque fois j'ai
g sur des grands créneaux.
Euh
je pense qu'on peut provoquer enfin j'ai
proposé quelque chose d'un peu différent
avec des modules en temps euh en soir,
l'hiver, les weekends sur un 2 jours 3
jours. Enfin puis je pense que on peut
proposer quelque chose de Ouais. Très
différent. Il y a de la place pour tout
le monde he de toute manière. Donc les
lieu de musque avec sa petite antenne
satellite, vous l'utilisez un peu sur
les bateaux ou pas du tout ? Ouais. Bah
c'est simple, nous on la donc on est
parti sans si ça si parce qu'on a envoyé
de la donnée, on a envoyé de la vidéo.
Euh on pouvait envoyer 3 minutes de
vidéo par semaine. On est loin des
des tr ou 4 minutes quotidiennes, voire
plus maintenant. Etth
malait très bien 3 minutes. C'était on
raconte beaucoup de choses en 3 minutes.
Et il y a un moment c'est le calcul il
est très vite fait. Quand j'en parlais
avec mes équipes quand on préparait le
tour du monde, je payais 3500 € pour 50
m. C'est petit 50 m Ouais. Euh pour en
par mois.
Et euh bah tu fais 8 mois de course, tu
fais l'addition, tu dis que tu as un bon
budget quand même pour payer ça quoi. Et
euh et puis avec une connexion qui va
être très lente et puis il y en a un qui
se pointe qui me dit "Bon alors j'ai une
solution, tu vas pas aimer. Vas-y. Bon,
ça va te coûter 300 € pour 50 Go par
mois. Génial ! Bon, par contre, c'est
Starlink. Ah, merde. Pourquoi ? Merde !
Ah écoute
avant on voit ce que ça a donné là mais
c'est pas forcément quelqu'un avec qui
j'aimerais dîner on va dire mais surtout
moi ce qui me enfin ça me c'est je
trouve ça assez terrifiant quand tu vois
le maillage. Il y a un maillage qui a
été mis en place le problème c'est qu'on
va avoir un deuxième maillage parce que
du coup Bossi vouloir faire le signal le
même les Européens voudront le même
chino les Chinois vont vouloir le même.
On a une pollution tu parles de la
constellation satellite. On a une
pollution déjà de satellite qui est
enfin c'est là-haut c'est une
déchetterie hein. C'est vois-toi en mer.
Alors non, on le voit. Ah, on a vu les
j'ai vu déjà les constellations, les
lancements Starlink. Euh,
j'ai même vu un lancement aux Antill
quand j'étais aux Antill, j'ai vu un CR
Dragon partir alors que c'était Cap
Canavérale et nous, on était euh on
était où ? Vous avez pu on est pas en
Antigo on était à côté enfin en course
Antibois ailleurs le truc c'est assez
assez assez dingue quand même à voir.
Mais par contre quand tu passes au point
NMO donc ça c'est au milieu du Pacifique
et c'est le l'endroit le plus éloigné de
toutes les terres et donc quand tu es au
point des mots les hommes le plus près
de toi c'est la station spatiale
internationale. Mais c'est aussi
l'endroit où on lâche les satellites en
fin de vie.
Et donc là, tu espères que bon,
normalement la enfin la probabilité d'en
prendre un est quand même assez faible,
mais ou alors tu as un coup de com
incroyable,
mais euh mais ouais, tu sais que ça
passe par là. Ouais. Est-ce que tu as
trois livres à nous conseiller, des
livres qui ont été importants pour toi ?
Euh le premier, sans hésiter, ce sera
Shakelton, l'Odsée de l'endurance.
Ça, j'adore. Shak Elton, la plus grande
expédition ratée de l'histoire.
C'est rien que la préface, elle est
démonte parce que c'est Paul Émil Victor
et et elle est déjà hyper inspirante.
Mais Shack Elton, c'est pour moi le plus
grand des leaders d'hom c'est Shakelton.
Enfin, il faut lire tout le livre et
puis on le lit, on bouffe he vraiment
euh
en sachant que ils s'en sortent à la fin
parce qu'à chaque page, tu dis "Non mais
là, ils vont crever les gars ! Là c'est
sûr, ils vont crever. Ils vont dans des
endroits pas possibles dans à une
époque, tu vois, ils sont 40
Bah ouais années des début des années
40.
Expédition polaire. Ouais. Pour aller
traverser, l'idée c'était d'aller
traverser
l'Antarctique et ils se font prendre par
les glaces, le bateau coule.
Ça a duré 2 ans et demi délire entre et
il a tout le monde
s'en est sorti vivant.
Donc ça ça reste
Ouais. Chaon
très très bon.
En deux euh
fou en deux en deux en deux. [__] il
y en a un paquet parce que si tu as
jamais lu un Jul Verne, faut quand même
faut quand même mettre ça.
Euh
bon, pour euh
j'ai beaucoup aimé moi le Ocean Songs de
Olivier de Carsaon.
Celui-là, il est moi, il m'a vraiment
vraiment fait voyager. Puis j'adore
Olivier, mais voilà, c'était vraiment un
livre que j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé.
Euh,
comment il s'appelle ton bouquin ? Moi,
cavalcade Océan. Euh, fa voir un peu à à
la télé là. En fait, c'était cavalcade
parce que ça reprenait évidemment le le
côté équestre. Pis Océan, c'est le
dernier livre écrit par Florence à
contrôle un peu plus haut parce que j'ai
mon caméraman qui comprend pas que le
pied une tête articulé. Et du coup, je
voulais faire un petit je voulais faire
un petit clin d'œil à Florence en même
temps. Du coup, je l' fait avec Cavalc
d'Océan. Ouais. Florence
et tu sais que mes rosiers s'appellent
comme ça. Ah ouais qu'il y a un rosier à
Barli aussi. C'est vrai ? Oui. Tu es pas
venu avec une bouture. Non je me balade
pas avec on fait du vin aussi, on fait
du RH si tu veux. Je me balade pas avec
tout. Ça alors la l'abus d'alcool est
dangereux pour la santé. Comment il
s'appelle ton R ? C'est le R On a sorti
un RH blanc bio euh sous
euh et le nom c'est Carnival hein. C'est
enfin c'est la marque Carnival. C'est un
type blanc ou c'est un agricole ? C'est
agricole. C'est agricole. Il est blanc.
Ah, il est blanc. Ouais. Bah oui, blanc
là. Il est blanc. Il est blanc mais
agricole. Non, il est très très bon. Il
est hyper yodé. Il est hyper fruité. Et
je l'ai choisi parce que je trouve que
c'est les gens ne connaissent pas très
bien le Rome et c'est enfin le Rome
blanc surtout. souvent l'impression que
c'est du torboyau et alors qu'en fait il
est il est tellement parfumé, tu mets
rien d'autre en fait dedans quoi. Moi
j'aime beaucoup voyager
via tuis les alcools, tu avec ta mais
olfactive.
Ouais, mais ça te ça tu as une explosion
de et puis tu comprends mieux en fait ce
qui se passe surtout avec bah surtout
avec le Rome parce que c'est quand même
enfin tu vois c'est vu l'histoire la
création du Rome avec tout
l'esclavagisme avec tout ce qui s'est
passé autour de j'aime bien j'aime bien
voyager
via le goût via la soit la la cuisine
euh voir tu les Écossais et les
Irlandais comment est-ce qu'ils vont
tuis tout ce que tout ce que le whisky
peut peut faire voyer J'aime beaucoup
ça. Ouais. Tu cuisines un peu ? J'adore.
Tu fais C'est quoi ton plat signature ?
J'ai euh j'ai pas de plat signature en
fonction vraiment en fonction des
saisons. Mais mais alors tout ce qui va
être bah tu quand tu viens chez moi, tu
viens faire un bon gueuleton quoi. Tu
J'hésite pas à faire des trucs
de l'agneau qui a été pendant que confie
pendant 5h, elle a étouffé
qui touche pas le jus mais tu vois.
Enfin, tu vois, je me débrouille pour
vous des trucs simples. Mais euh mais
par contre, je ma mère ma mère était une
excellente cuisinière. J'ai toujours eu
des souvenir de grande table avec plein
de gens hyper convivial. Mais par
contre, tu manges bien et c'est tu
prends le temps. Ouais. Le paradoxe
français. Ah ouais, j'adore ça quoi.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à la
mer. Je crois que je crois que
d'ailleurs cette phrase avec toi, ça
raisonne beaucoup mieux qu'avec tous les
autres. Une bouteille à la mer, quelque
chose d'impérissable pour les jeunes
générations.
Stresse pas comme ça. Non, je stresse
pas. Mais en fait, c'est tellement
compliqué un un conseil en fait.
Mais je pense que si les gens étaient
eux-mêmes, mais pour ce qu'ils sont eux
réellement et pas
euh bah je dois être ça parce que la
société me dit que je dois faire ça
parce que parce que en général entre on
fait plus attention enfin tout le monde
répond à des envies et plus à ses
besoins en fait. Donc mais si les gens
c'étaient les tris/4 des conflits, c'est
parce que c'est des gens qui sont très
très mal dans leur peau quand même. Euh
donc je pense que si les gens étaient
eux-mêmes, ce serait bien. Donc soyez
vous-mêmes en fait. C'est très très
simple et à la fois très compliqué mais
je pense que les gens se se porteraient
bien mieux. Ouais. Marie Tabarli, merci.
Mais merci à toi
[Musique]